okay well welcome back everybody it was
a nice uh
nice break and uh we're we are
in the yellow b and partially on zoom
for those from the public that are
watching that there'll be opportunities
for you to testify
uh shortly if you so wish but let's get
started with uh
some notification that will include uh
zoom notification with regard to our
disclosure agreements now as chair as
the
municipal and county government
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covert 19 pandemic
in accordance with house rule 67 in the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on all bills referred to the committee
an executive session may follow
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronics calendar
on the general court website
the notice for this meeting notice
complies with house rules
and rsa 91-8 anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600
or email us at hps at
ledge.state.nh.us.com
[Music]
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
christina dyer is the staff
member who is assisting us please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there's
anybody
in the room with you during this meeting
if you're if you're connecting via zoom
which is required under the right to
note
i'm here and i'm home alone
representative guthrie yes
representative lasalles here in the uh
legislative office building uh
representative
representative mcbride representative
melvin
here in the lb representative here
representative
i am here in exeter i'm along the room
my husband is elsewhere in the house
thank you representative here in the lb
representatives davis i'm here and
home alone representative
i am here at home in nashua
with my fur buddy
representative um i'm here
in peterborough in my house i'm alone in
the room i know
my name is i am in and my husband is
elsewhere in the house
hey uh representative i am here
i can hear the proceedings i'm alone in
this room at the moment
my husband um is in the house but i use
a headset
so he cannot hear the proceedings and
representative gallagher
i'm here in my apartment in concord
and i'm allowed
thank you okay uh at this point
could i ask you to rise and join me in
the pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag in the
united states
one nation under god liberty
and justice for all thank you please be
seated
i hope i hope you all are doing well i'm
glad to see
folks back in the love the rules have
changed so the
mask rule is optional at this point
and so we encourage those of you who
feel comfortable
to join us live in
we have uh three bills we're going to
look at today senate bill 84
86 and 88
a schedule is such that we won't be
exacting
any bills today uh so once we have these
three hearings we'll be finished
uh but next monday we'll hear three more
bills
three more senate bills and we will
eject all six of them
afterwards which will probably take us
into the afternoon so our schedule will
be a little bit longer next friday
uh than it is uh today
um there is a couple of these bills
where we have a long list of people who
wish to testify
so uh if you are on that list and you're
called to testify i
ask you to be mindful of of the time and
uh
please make your comments brief
and and if you feel like your comments
have been
uh said before and and
you're just going to repeat with someone
else that it would
certainly is acceptable for you to say i
agree with what's already been said
and uh and cut your comments
i know the committee would appreciate it
but you're certainly uh
able to be heard today so with that
uh first up today is senate bill 84
which is uh
has to do with uh village district
public bodies
it's uh it's a bill that provides that
every legislative body governing body
award commissioner committee
uh shelby deemed a public body on the
rsa rs891a we subject to all the
applicable revisions of that chapter in
our statutes
so those wishing to testify
we have
christina snyder uh
and we have ellen reed and cordell
johnson
uh why don't we start with uh ellen reed
are you online ella
i am mr chair can you hear me you can
just fine please go right ahead
uh thank you so much uh mr chair and
honorable members um
just as a preface and by the way as an
introduction my name is ellen reed i
am the state representative for
rockingham 17 new market in newfields
and um it sounds like you don't have
anyone speaking to the bill
as it stands before you now from the
senate
um i wish to speak to an amendment that
re-inserts the original
language of sb 84 um as senator reagan
had
introduced it in the senate so if
there's anyone who wants to speak to the
original bill i don't know if you would
like to take
those people first but it sounds like
you have a pretty short list
yeah no we don't have anybody in the
senate signed up to speak
is there anybody online from the senate
that would like to speak that i don't
have a record up
no i guess not so reagan uh excuse me mr
chair senator reagan
is online okay senator reagan senator
reagan uh you have the floor if you'd
like to speak to the bill
either of my uh technical experts you
should you have her online senator
reagan if uh
just make sure you're off mute you're
welcome to go right ahead
okay members of municipal and county
government
mr chairman i bring before you today
senate bill 84 relative to village
district public bodies
and the chairman read the whole content
of the bill
so that's as it stands
these whoever is offering an amendment i
know nothing about it
was not shown the courtesy of having it
sent to me
so i don't know what that's all about
but the bill of course is in your hands
okay thank you anything uh any nuances
about this bill
senator no it just prevents
the village districts from being exempt
from right to know
okay are there any questions from the
committee
to the senator yes uh representative
reporter
thank you mr chair i'm not sure if this
uh question
can be asked at this point um my
understanding about the amendment
is that it includes language that was in
the original bill in the senate
and i was wondering if the senator would
be able to tell us why it was removed
but i don't know if that's appropriate
now because well it sends us i mean
representative reed who you heard from
just briefly
is the author of the amendment so maybe
we could wait till
her uh testimony
the substance of the amendment
is language that was in senator reagan's
bill originally
and was removed in the senate senator
ray could you advise us as to
why that language was removed
no i have no idea thank you
okay are there any questions other
questions yes representative
power thank you mr chairman um
thank you senator reagan for taking my
question i'm curious to know if there
have been any
incidences in which a village district
um is not cooperating with the right to
know
such occasions well if they're if
they're exempted they
don't even have to worry about it
thank you any other questions from the
committee
either online or in the llb i'm looking
are there any questions from the public
to senator reagan
there being none uh thank you
i'm sorry i'm sorry mr chair i noticed
that representatives davis has her hand
up
oh yes she does i'm sorry uh
representative status
go right ahead thank you mr chair um
senator reagan you mentioned that um
village districts were exempt from 91a
is that explicitly stated in new
hampshire law that they are
currently exempt
yeah that's or they're not mentioned or
they're not
included but they're not specifically
exempted
what's your point are they specifically
exempted in the law statute in front of
me
so my main objective uh representative
davis are you hinting at
why what's the purpose of this uh the
i'm actually not hinting at anything i'm
just inquiring as to what the current
law states
[Music]
okay
representative reagan are you uh
contemplating that
that answer are you good i'm sorry
representative uh
senator right now please accept my
apology are you contemplating that
answer
are you you think you've uh answered it
all right that's the information i have
and i don't have the statute in front of
me
and i'm on a caucus at this present time
aaron dylan i can send out the link to
the statute if that would be helpful
okay thank you all right thank you
senator i'm gonna go on to
uh representative reed
thank you mr chair and thank you again
i've already introduced myself
uh i would like to once again preface by
saying
i have my apologies if senator reagan is
still on i hope he can hear me
that he did not receive any of my
communications to him
either i both called and left a message
for his assistant and i called his
personal number
as well and left a message there saying
that i wanted to reintroduce or rather
put an amendment that reintroduced his
original language
but you can rest assured and you can
certainly verify i've sent you the
amendment
of all the committee members um and
verify with the
language that it was introduced that was
introduced in the senate that it is
verbatim
exactly word for word the exact uh
uh bill that uh senator reagan
introduced
um so with that uh and again my
apologies
to senator reagan that he didn't receive
any of my communications
um i would like to talk about the
original purpose of this bill
uh sb 84 and let me just be clear i am
not giving testimony on the
municipal amendment that was added in
the senate that is before you now
um i cannot speak to it i have not
reviewed it i'm not giving an opinion on
that
the original sb84 is what's known as a
purple paint law
perhaps some of you have heard of this
or seen this before
many states have already adopted this
the issue that exists and the reason
many states have adopted this
is um particularly in rural states with
um
especially with a prominent hunting
community landowners have to post
their land as no trespassing in order to
prevent people from coming onto the land
the way our current rsa
stands currently is that in order to
post
you have to purchase signs that have
specific size lettering
includes your name includes your address
and those signs have to be every 100
yards
and so for a property with a relatively
large perimeter this isn't just
expensive but it's also very time
consuming
and there's been all stories of people
getting texts posting but the main
issue is that the signs themselves are
very
uh susceptible to storm damage and also
tampering
um there have been multiple instances
that have gone to court um
of hunter's unethical hunters uh
tampering with signs in order to kind of
excuse going on to the property
um i personally serve on the fish and
game committee and this has been an
issue
that um really has taken off recently
which has been a huge
struggle between the uh the landowner
community that is concerned about their
privacy rights
and some other members in the hunting
community not all
um and that is that um recently maybe
some of you know that these wildlife
cameras
not the ones that you have to go and
physically check the sd card
but there's a new kind of wildlife
camera that's being produced relatively
inexpensively
that immediately pings your phone
and live streams video now our current
rsa
or our current statute allows anyone to
put these
wildlife cameras on properties so long
as that property
uh private property is not posted so the
problem is
the and this is why the landowners
association and why the new hampshire
farm bureau was very much in favor of
senator reagan's bill
um people can essentially put
for lack of a better term spy cameras on
your private property and
immediately see if you are on your
property what you're doing
etc so um the
in the senate hearing this had
absolutely no opposition and testimony
it had very very broad-based bipartisan
support
senator reagan obviously was the sponsor
but senator guida and senator bradley
both
supported it as well as senator waters
senator and senator rebecca
cuoca perkins and also the communities
that i just mentioned the new hampshire
landowners association the new hampshire
farm bureau
and officials from the new hampshire
fish and game department
specifically uh colonel jordan and paul
sanderson i
paul sanderson specifically who is the
legal counsel for the new hampshire fish
and game department
said that he would be joining to testify
on this
i didn't hear you read his name so i
don't know if he's coming in late but if
he doesn't make it today
then i'm sure he will send along a
message about the necessity regarding
of issue they've been having about
landowner
privacy um now that whole issue about
you know whether or not people can put
up cameras that's something that will be
dealt with later
but all of the stakeholders have agreed
that making posting easier
cheaper and more tamper resistant is
something that we can all do and this is
why so many states have already adopted
this
um somewhere in the teens i i apologize
i don't know the specific number but
it's definitely more than
10 states and again they're mostly uh
rural states that have a prominent
hunting community like
new hampshire um but again it's just is
so much cheaper so much
quicker and easier and tamper resistant
um
the other thing is that um and i know
this may seem like a small thing but
there's several
studies and articles already on the
issue with the rising cost of lumber
many of these landowners will timber
their their land
if they have to post they have to put it
currently with signage
then they have to put nail holes into
their trees which does damage their
lumber
and reduces the the um quality and
therefore the
the price that they can get um and a
couple questions i've heard
previously about this that i've gone
through the trouble of researching the
answers for
the first question that i heard was well
how do we distinguish purple markings
from trail markings so there's a few
things
again this is so ubiquitous that
actually several
paint companies create a a color a
purple spray paint color specifically
for the purposes of posting
um so it's so ubiquitous that people who
do trails no longer use the color purple
but in addition trail markings
themselves are
usually either circle or square little
pieces of plastic mailed to a tree
in the case of paint they may be
horizontal
uh hashings but not uh long
vertical stripes which is what this and
other states
um set as the purple paint the other
thing is that if there were existing
purple
marked trails which have probably been
changed by now
um if there are existing purple mark
trails those are on
property that's not posted so anyone
who's wishing to post their land
obviously a trail
is not marked that's already crossing
into their land so there would not be
any confusion the last question i'll
bring up that i've heard is the issue of
publicity how do
we make sure people know this and the
fish and game department
had you know issues licenses every uh
every year
and has to do education every year on
on the rules and regulations and as well
as statute
for hunters such as open seasons proper
methods of take what caliber weapon can
be used
when does both seasons start those types
of things um and so this is just part of
would be part of their normal
uh education process that happens every
year
um i realize i might seem like i'm
rambling saul in there
and take any questions
we have any questions from the municipal
committee
representative reed
see eddie let me ask representative reed
this
appears to be from hearing from
senator reagan by
a law to govern
the uh the privacy issue or 91a
uh the right to know provision of our
statutes
but you you're talking mostly about
hunting and so forth is so what's the
connection that you see
trespassing so let me be very clear as
senator reagan introduced sb 84
it did not have anything to do with 91a
or municipal issues
it was the purple paint law as is
written in the amendment that i have
emailed to all of you
um the senate decided to use sb 84
as a vehicle for this municipal 91a
piece that i cannot speak to
so they had added this non-germain
amendment which is why it's before you
now instead of in fish and game the
original understanding was that
sb 84 was likely to go to fish and game
because it was the purple paint law
which is why i am involved so i cannot
speak to you as the bill stands before
you right now
because the non-german amendment that
the senate uh added my understanding
um because there was absolutely no
opposition and there was huge support
from multiple groups as well as
bipartisan senators my understanding is
that
the senate committee decided to use sb
84 as a vehicle for this 91a
piece and um kind of
as an oversight replaced the entire bill
which was not something that they were
you know particularly passionate about
um instead of simply adding it to the
bill so just to be clear
my amendment that i've sent before you
simply adds it does not replace the
municipal
91a piece that is before you but it add
re-adds the original language
back into the bill as senator reagan
um had originally had well um
representative reed you are the the
clerk on the fish and game
subcommittee is that correct i am the
vision game committee yes
yes are you would you uh advise that
this
uh bill uh as amended ought to be
reviewed by that committee um
i would i i i hesitate to make my chair
mad at me
[Laughter]
but um i'm hap i personally would be
happy
to review in our committee but i'm also
because there was no opposition at all
and i am confident that the chair of our
committee has no opposition to this
um that i'm happy for this committee to
just rule on it
uh as well so it is up to your
discretion mr chair
okay thank you uh yes representative
thank you uh mr recognize me and thank
you
representative reed for taking my
question um i just
want to make sure in your amendment
which adds the purple paint
back it also makes if i if i read this
correctly
it makes writing in the name and the
address of the landowner
or keeps it optional is that correct
correct so it doesn't
remove the current language that so the
current language in that second section
is what currently exists in terms of
what we need to post and as you can see
it's a little bit
uh complicated i guess is the word and
so instead of removing
all of that language it simply says that
that is optional
um so if if people wanted to be
really super clear two letter tall no
trespassing and just to be clear
it's no trespassing it's not no hunting
so it's inclusive of no hunting but it's
simply no trespassing
um but two inch tall no trespassing
letters with their name and address and
everything if they wanted to do that
they still
can and that would still be considered
they wouldn't have to use purple paint
in addition to that
is the point of keeping that language in
and adding in optional
primarily for people who have already
posted their land in that method
okay thank you any other questions from
the committee
representative
see none uh very much is christina
snyder
there to speak uh member of the public
hello uh yes this is christina snyder
can you hear me
yesterday hi uh thank you um
yes my name is christina snyder i'm from
chester new hampshire
uh rockingham district four is my um
district for the house of
representatives and i'm just here to uh
voice my support of this amendment and
um this comes down to me an issue of
making it easier to exercise your
property rights
um i moved to chester in 2015 and we do
post our property
which is our right to do um it it is
actually a tedious process
to do this properly we have to actually
lug the ladder
with some nails signs and we have to go
around to the perimeter of the property
and put nails in our trees
and uh as representative reed mentioned
nails do
inhibit the growth of our trees and also
increase the tree's vulnerability to
disease so
we hate to do it but yet we'd like to
exercise our property rights
so so what we do is we go around and we
put these signs up
however inevitably the signs are
generally ripped down within a short
period of time
and we also have had issues of animals
chewing
up the signs we think that flying
squirrels use some of the material for
nests
and then so we change to a harder
plastic sign
and we notice that those are also being
chewed as well
um so the animals people do uh take down
the signs
and it's it's a tedious process and i
think it it should not
be this difficult to exercise your
property rights
uh people have the right to post their
property and it could be for any reason
uh they could have no trespass because
they have sensitive habitat
and um there are actually some hunters
that post their own property
and and it's it's their right to do so
and
in in addition um some things that just
in discussions with other people
is is the way that this method is now it
is
it's very difficult for for uh elderly
people for disabled
people for for those uh property rights
owners to be able to do something like
this they have to ask for help
now if this were to change to the purple
paint method it's it's it's very easier
it's uh from my understanding the the
the paint line only has to be between
three and five feet off the ground you
don't have to bring a ladder and post
these signs up high
to try to keep them out of uh reach of
of people
that might be taking them down um it's
it's just that over over the years we've
just had so many issues
that that you might even want to give up
and it it just comes down again to
i'll reiterate one last time it's just
property rights it
you know other states have been been
taking this up across the country i
believe maine does it
um i think it's the way to go it's the
way it's going to be it's just going to
make it easier for property owners
and for all people uh to to be able to
do
to use this method and um so i just will
end with
i uh have my i hope you support this
amendment
thank you
okay uh thank you um
we spent a lot of time talking about
this amendment to
sba for this is really not the
appropriate time to be
discussing an amendment since nobody has
nobody that's been noticed
to speak to this bill has that amendment
representative ford did you come in i do
i want to let you know that
representative truleven notified me that
she's having trouble getting into the
meeting
so it's a technical issue or something
i'll give her a call
thank you christine and secondly i'm
assuming then that you don't want me to
ask
this person yeah i think i'd like to uh
i think i'd let it go on tomorrow
thank you i think i'd like to end the
discussion and then that the amendment
is really not before us yet
that will have to be introduced by a
member of this uh committee
if if if uh if it's needed
uh and i'd also uh like to discuss the
fact that
that uh the majority of what we've
spoken to so far
i i don't think is is uh
apropos for the municipal county
committee
i believe that this really needs to be
seen by the official name
committee and i will take the action to
contact the chair of that committee to
see
if they want to take this bill and hear
it or if they just want to
advise us as to how we are forward yes
i have a question mr chairman do we have
the authority to separate
the two sections of this build and make
it
as to control it was originally two
separate builds
although they've combined the two
uh subject matters that really don't
belong together
okay if we would pass to
pass 84 senate bill 84
to the fishing game would the first
section also
be uh sent to
yes that that being that we have to
it's been referred to us so with we have
the
uh the authority and the responsibility
to rule on this bill
uh although i i have the freedom to
uh consult with the chair of the uh
the other committee the fish and game
committee to see if they want to take on
a second committee responsibility to
hear this as well
then we would put our thoughts together
to decide how we wanted to
approve so
not being too cute no we can't split the
bill up and have two bills now
it's it's not that we won't even do that
next session we couldn't do that this
session
all right if i could concern is i think
the first section
for no law on the open meeting
law rather certainly belongs here
right it does so um
well i guess the way we handled that is
we could bring the two
committees together and have a joint
committee meeting
uh or uh we could also uh
my discussions with the clerk
uh we could just get advice from the
other committee that we think
is affected by this and move from that
so
i think we've heard from representative
reid uh
she's the clerk of the other committee
and it's
her her judgment that the committee
chair has no problem with uh
moving forward with this language as is
but i'd like to speak to him myself
representative lang is the chair of that
committee and i'll speak to him before
we get back
together to accept this next one mr
chair if i may just insert very quickly
um
so first of all the amendment is before
i have emailed it to all of you so you
have access to it but you are correct
that had the senate amended this
in the way i think they intended which
is to simply add the municipal police it
would have created essentially an
omnibus
and our committee the fish and game
committee has
weighed in on pieces of omnibuses in
other committees that affected our
committee
um and advised them so that you mr chair
you are correct that that would be the
the procedure right so i i'll do
i'll take the action do that between now
and our next meeting on
the but uh we still
the floor is still open others have
questions and
we have anyone else in the public that
has presented themselves to speak to
this
we have also nhma uh cordell johnson
that's
signed up to speak uh mr johnson are you
are you there with us
yes i am uh thank you mr chairman and
committee members
um and and we we neither support nor
oppose this bill but
i think maybe i can provide some
clarification
and i am speaking on the bill as
presented to you
uh nothing at all about the amendment
this bill as introduced in the senate
was an
omnibus bill there were two parts
introduced by senator reagan that had to
do with posting of land
part three introduced by senator waters
had to do with village districts being
subject to the right to know law
so this provision was in the bill all
along
um but it was senator waters it was
senator waters
uh part of the bill not senator reagan's
which i think is why senator reagan
uh may not have been able to answer all
of the questions
so um i'm only speaking to to this part
and as i said in the senate this
this doesn't really change the law
it's already clear that village district
that public bodies of village districts
are subject to the right to know law
but the right to know law i think does
not expressly
refer to village districts it talks
about political subdivisions
and a village district very definitely
is a
political subdivision but apparently
there were in senator waters district
some one or two village districts where
the
commissioners or others seemed to think
they were not
subject to the right to know law so he
wanted to put this in
just to make it absolutely clear that
they are
so that seems to speak to the question
representative status had earlier yes
the
yeah she asked whether whether they were
specifically exempted from the right to
know law
and the answer is no they're not
specifically exempted
they're not specifically mentioned but
um
they are a political subdivision uh and
therefore they are subject to the right
to know law
so um and my testimony in the senate was
i think
uh as i said the bill the bill doesn't
really change the law
but if if you think it is helpful to
clarify
uh for people in village districts that
they are subject to the right to know
law
then i think that it probably is useful
and and that's all i have for you but
i'd be happy to answer questions
thank you mr johnson are there any
questions from the committee
for the nhma
seeing none i believe that's the end of
our testimony unless we have anyone else
from the
public who has uh signed up
or a step forward and i'm
getting indication
so in conclusion what i'm going to do is
i will
speak with the chair of the fish and
game committee
and uh get there uh feeling like if
representative gallagher
beat me to the punch from for um when i
had it up earlier
i was just temporarily raising it again
now because i thought i saw that
paul smith what that clerk paul smith
was
um raising his hand to point that out
but
it seems he's disappeared so never mind
mr clerk do you have a comment you'd
like to say
uh yes mr chairman thank you uh so just
to be clear
the bill before you uh today
is what's before you any amendment that
has to deal with anything outside of the
purview of this legislation that needs
any involvement from another committee
is going to need a non-germane public
amendment hearing
so i want to just be clear on that
because um
any anything that's not within this bill
text
uh as it came to you whether it was
introduced in the senate and and not
adopted or not
um is is not germane to this bill
um you know what what the senate does
the senate does
uh anything that that you know is
outside of the norm
uh of this committee's purview uh is not
really germane and you'll need a
non-german amendment
your hearing is that uh needed to be
accomplished next monday when we
uh accept the bill uh if you're going to
have a non-germain amendment public
hearing you're going to have to notice
it
and that amendment is going to have to
be available
for people to testify on before you
go into executive session and a little
inside baseball do we have
time now to notice it for next monday
um yes you you would
i would just i would just caution you
however as
um as anything that that isn't within
the purview of this
committee by rule uh that is
those things that may affect other
policy areas
really shouldn't be adopted by the this
policy committee
um you know in terms of uh
in terms of what you wish to do with the
bill that's before you
um that really would be the purview of
another policy committee
to do that with a bill that's in their
possession so
um mr clerk what would you advise would
you
advise to transfer this to the fish and
date committee uh well you can't do that
now because uh we've you've had a public
hearing on it and
frankly this bill has nothing to do with
fishing game um
it has to do with right what about the
amendment
um i would suggest that you know if if
uh if
the member um wishes to have
uh you know that a piece that that deals
with with fish and game law
um that that should go through its own
its own committee um uh internal
committee in the senate
well i i will say that the senate still
has possession of many house bills and
the senate has has far less stringent
rules than we do about germaness and
if the senate wished to add something in
on their side they could certainly do
that
um or i do believe that the fish and
game committee
may have already passed out the the
bills that were in there
within their purview to deal with um but
uh
you know the legislative session still
has another year to go so
okay uh why don't we take this offline i
think i need a little more
advice absolutely mr clerk and
we'll just we'll make a decision yes
very secretive
here i asked if we could separate the
bill
can in fact the senate separate the bill
separate the two parts of the bill
i know the question is clear i'm not i'm
not sure i
i understand i think what he's saying is
could the senate
have a bill on 91a and then also a then
a second bill on the purple payment
the senate again the senate can do
whatever the senate wants
as you as you know there have been bills
that the senate passed that that deal
with
12 different policy areas uh at once
um so i i mean um
they they can they can
they can do what they want but the bill
before you as it is
currently um is you know it deals with
three specific things
um third-party inspections the housing
and conservation planning program and
uh prohibiting the installation of of
heating systems
i mean that's that's what's before you
uh other things
beyond that are not before you and and
that's that's the point okay thank you
mr appreciate your clarification
thank you okay any other
comments yes this is all just uh all
just uh
technical things i want to note that
representative
has joined the meeting by phone thank
you welcome and
i do see a hand up i i don't i don't
remember if you closed the hearing but i
do see it end up
not from linda dion not on the list i
don't see her on the next
hearing either so i leave it to
certainly for the chair of discretion
but bring
your attention okay uh miss diane did
you want to speak to
senate bill 84
you're currently on you
yes yes i would like to yes go right
ahead
okay my name is linda dion i live in
raymond new hampshire
i'm the constituent that wanted this
purple paint bill
to begin with now what i'd like to say
is that this
the purple paint part of the bill is not
before us the only products before us is
the 91a
uh portion of the bill the the rest of
it is
needs a new disposition okay okay
no i please let me see it say this okay
this is not a fishing game bill i don't
know why you're calling it a fishing
game bill
it is a criminal trespass bill it's
about
no trespassing now we're getting it
confused that it's all about no hunting
and it's not
it's a criminal trespass bill
this bill would not go to fish and game
okay well we're going to take this
offline and we're going to decide where
it goes
but the point question that bill
assuming doesn't belong in front of the
discipline council
i think it might do you handle criminal
trespass bills
would go to a criminal trespass
committee whoever handles that it will
not go to fish and game
fishing game has nothing to do with this
bill
yeah we will we will decide offline
uh the best the best venue for this okay
i just wanted to clear that up
you seem to think this is official game
bill it is not a fish and game bill
thank you for your input okay thank you
yes representative no it's okay you
think it's you think it's criminal
justice
i don't know who it is yeah i just i
just wanted to
talk with representative guthrie about
separating the bill
i don't know if you haven't closed the
hearing yet though
i don't think right now the bill before
us representative doesn't have two parts
to separate it only has one and that's
the right to know heart
it would have two parts if we amended it
with this amendment but right now it
doesn't so
separating it isn't something that we
can do because it's only got one part
does that answer your question yeah yeah
yeah
the second part is is not there it's
just floating in the air
right what i'm going to do so there's no
mystery i'm going to sit with the
house leadership for the folks who would
sign these bills to the various
committees
and i'm going to present this as a
section of the bill that doesn't
it shouldn't be assigned to our
committee and they're going to use their
expertise inside
which is science or how it should be
deficient
mr chairman i just don't understand
some of these on the bus bills not just
one in particular
anymore but it seems like
when we get into on the bus that really
gets
murky great and i'm wondering how the
animals
when there's europe in favor of say
section one and two but you don't like
sect
three right i don't know if you're
drawing in they have to vote for all
three so what we can do
one of our options is to delete sections
of bills and senate bills that come to
us that we can delete sections
that we don't care for
we could offer an amendment that would
delete section two with section four or
whatever section
that's hopefully we don't get it right
and then
one of the options at the end is to go
to a community of conference which is
that can be often kind of messy but
that's when the senate doesn't agree
with what we're doing we don't know
what they're doing they're not a
committee is signed fight it out
decide
i'm sorry to interrupt um i i just
wanted to point out
i'm sorry i was referencing the wrong
bill i was referencing the next bill i
didn't know exactly where you were when
when
i was called in to uh to to chat with
you all i apologize i thought you were
on 86 i didn't realize you were in 84.
but that being said 84 my comment stands
that 84 before you
is is a one bill uh frankly it's a
two-sentence bill that that deals with
public body it has nothing to do
with how it was introduced um and again
uh you know so i just wanted to clarify
the issue before you is as
it is uh presented to you sorry
my uh my strategy is to go back to the
speaker's office and talk to the
those by his staff that have signed
these bills
um representative dylan i will tell you
the speaker and i sat down and assigned
all these bills and the bill
was assigned correctly because the the
the one sentence that has to do with you
um is what the text is what the text
doesn't matter but with the with the
amendment now
showing itself is this should just be
assigned to somebody else
the amendment is not germane um if if
you all want to add it as a non-german
amendment
that's that's what within your purview
but i but what i'm trying to suggest to
you is
because of the elements that that that
bill contains
does not belong to the purview of this
committee and that's why it's
it's it's objectionable okay thank you
all right uh i believe that's the the
last comment to be heard on senate bill
84 that's before us at this point
there's still some work to be done
and i have the answers might i make him
comment please
sure go ahead uh
it appears that uh the only reason that
the amendment
might be added is because it was
added it was uh present in the bill
previously i would suggest that uh
if they want to add the amendment that
they
add it to a bill that it would be
germaine to
not rather not giving it to us since we
haven't had
opportunity to get the amendment yet
that is
it's not really pertinent you know i
would i would suggest that uh
representative reed find a bill that the
amendment is pertinent to and uh
get somebody on that committee to uh add
it
thank you all right so i'm closing the
hearing on senate bill 84
and now opening the hearing on senate
bill 86.
chairman you have senator um khan
available to
open up the hearing thank you senator
khan
welcome to the municipal county house
committee uh the floor is yours if you'd
like to open the hearing
i thank you chairman dolan i appreciate
being here with you today
to introduce senate bill 86
the bill was considered by municipal
and election affairs committee
in the senate
earlier this year it passed
uh 5-0 in that committee
went to the floor of the senate and
passed 23-1
with all three parts as are presented to
you
uh if i speak
uh primarily to part one which is the
part that
i am responsible for and i
believe that both uh senators
perkins cuoca and senator morris are
prepared to
testify on parts two and three uh
i'll stay on uh in the event that
they're not present
um part one
is a bill that was introduced in
2019 and
uh it needed some additional work
uh the bill that was passed in 2020
is now the bill that is in front of you
do you can recall the 2020 session
uh there were a lot of bills that passed
from one chamber
and uh were unable to be considered in
the second chamber
uh in this case uh part one
uh was senate bill uh 151
it passed in 2020 and then
uh was no longer considered uh
because uh of covid uh in the house
during 2020. so here it is reintroduced
um while it was introduced in 2019 there
was
concern that the
association of general contractors and
the new hampshire municipal association
needed to come together to work on the
bill
the bill is trying to
allow planning boards several routes
for how to do third party inspections of
construction
projects
because when there are smaller projects
and a third party becomes involved
uh it adds additional costs both to the
contractor
and it's hurting new hampshire
contractors
when these are small inspections
the original contractor who has a stamp
either architectural
or engineering uh can verify
that the project is being built to plan
and provide that assurance back to the
planning department
that's what the bill allows but if the
planning board
in the municipality wishes to have that
third-party review
if they think that it's important on on
a particular project
then they'll insist on that and uh and
go forward so it gives them several
routes
um in the end the both parties are very
supportive of the bill in addition
the new hampshire board of realtors
and new hampshire housing are also
supportive and
[Music]
and we had very supportive testimony in
the hearing so
i'd be glad to answer questions on part
one of the bill
i'm here to be uh introducing
uh at least a part of senate bill 88
as you follow but then i need to be in
uh
i'm sorry i need to be in the uh house
finance committee at 11. so
there's my schedule for the morning uh i
hope to be with you as long as i can to
to answer any questions thank you
senator senator connor you were
here to only speak to section one or do
you speak to section two and three as
well
uh i i as i believe i
i will if necessary but if
senators perkins cuoco for part two
and senator morris for part three are
present i would
encourage you to hear the testimony from
them
okay thank you uh any questions for
senator khan on
section one representative uh
representative statements
as our candidate mr chair okay
representatives davis go right ahead
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question
um question pertains to section
roman numeral two in part one
um it is line
21 of that section and it says develop a
scope for the project inspection
in consultation with the applicant
did you envision that consultation
being anything more than a consultation
in other words
would the applicant have the authority
or the power
should this bill become law to reject
us a project scope that a planning board
might recommend
thanks for the question representative
no
i don't believe that there is any veto
authority
uh over what the planning board will
ultimately do
i i think the uh contractors
are interested in just having a voice in
the process so that they can advise
uh if there are
complicated steps in the process and
when the third party might be
necessary for a phase or a particular
part of a project
and they can they can just work that out
it is the negotiation that i think that
the
contractors were looking for the
opportunity to have some input
but not there's no expectation of the
veto authority
thank you anyone else
on the committee like to ask senator
khan any questions about section
one
i think uh thank you senator appreciate
your time and
uh good luck with your your next
testimony yeah you are my next testimony
and
if uh i'll be here until 11. thank you
did anyone else that's on our testimony
list
wish to speak to section one you would
raise your hand for our our
committee to be able to see you wish you
could speak
mr looks like the several hands are up
the first one was from senator
perkins quoca and then we have in order
on the list here gary abbott
and fordell johnson uh seemingly in
response to your question
i think the senator program's copeland
is planning to speak
to section two
she should be allowed to talk now if you
want to confirm that
senator perkins poker are you well would
you like to wait to section two or do
you want to weigh in on section one
no that's correct chairman i'm here to
present part two thank you
okay uh mr johnston
cordell johnson do you want to speak to
this section section one or a different
section
uh yes um actually i i want to speak on
all three sections but i'll only do
section one now okay um
as senator khan indicated this is
something that was
uh negotiated uh among several parties
their contractors have had concerns
about
municipalities hiring
engineers or others to inspect their
construction process and overbilling
them
and this was a this is a a compromise
that we came up with represented
quite a bit of discussion among the
municipal association the associated
general contractors
i think the association of uh civil
engineers that's probably not the exact
their exact name but um this is what we
came up with
and uh it's something that i think we're
all willing to live with so i would
encourage you
not to change this language
any changes you make are probably gonna
going to
make one party um unhappy and we'll have
to go back to the drawing board so
i encourage you to uh to stick with the
language that is in part one
thank you any other comments on section
one
there is one other hand up mr chair from
gary abbott
mr abbott uh you want to comment on
section one
yes thank you uh chairman dolan and
thank you uh committee members uh
i'll be brief in light of both cordell
johnson's testimony and senator carnes
senator curran explained it really well
it started out as senate bill
152 back in 2019
the language was worked on over a year
with cordell and others
and we we did get to this language
it really is a simple language doesn't
take any authority away from
municipalities
but it involves the applicant where
there are uh
costs involved and these costs can be
anywhere from
thirty thousand to a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars uh that the
applicant or the contractor pays
i just want to let you know that the
senate
in 2020 passed this by voice vote
this was a separate bill all by itself
it wasn't part of an omnibus
it was too bad of covid that uh we ended
up that it was vacated
and wasn't acted upon so uh it's great
that senator khan resubmitted this bill
uh it ends up as an omnibus but it's
section one
we totally support it as the language as
it's drafted in there
i think it gives some new opportunities
for municipalities and with that
i would answer any questions you might
have thank you
uh administrative leader 1007
representative joining me
uh are there any questions from the
committee for mr abbott
dr abbott is by the way a lobbyist from
the associated general contractors of
new hampshire
well i'm sorry yeah i should explain
that i'm the executive vice president of
the associated general contractors of
new hampshire
any uh any questions mr abbott
seeing none is there anyone else who'd
like to speak to section one that has
not spoken
yes uh representative powell i had my
hands raised and i have a question i
would like to
thank you for taking my question um i
was seeking clarification with regard to
the nature of the project inspection i
wanted to know specifically
does the inspection does it abide by
rsa building codes or local municipality
codes
can somebody um describe that and second
part of my question
is the language in the bill here
states to develop a scope so what
exactly is meant by scope
that plan of how
the um inspection is going to be
administered mr abby you want to take a
shower sure
sure um yeah this uh pertains to there
are two
processes for the municipality
one prior to the approval of a project
there is a review that the contractor
pays by a third party
engineer or inspector kind of thing
this section pertains to the second
phase in which we're talking about
a on-site inspection of while it's being
built so
say a connection between a sewer line
to the new property that kind of thing
it is site work inspection
so the scope involves the communication
we're looking for
is that the applicant knows the phases
the timing the proper scope so working
with the municipality
that's the scope we're looking for is
that they talk about the phase and
rather than have somebody try to do an
inspection 365 days a year
they can focus in on this is going to
take place in the month of may
so that's how the scope fits in there
but this really still doesn't give and
and i think you got the right
answer before earlier is that the town
could do whatever they want to do but
this allows the applicant to have say
as we try to save money over the project
in what's necessary for third-party
inspection so that's where scope comes
in
it all depends on what is actually
required to do and what isn't required
for the inspection
so having all the parties know what that
means
is so important early on in the project
that everybody works together
that's really that will create less
problems that we currently have because
in some cases there's no communication
this will at least get that ball started
in in a very nice way that that's
how the functioning of the project is
going to go i hope i
answered your question
sure so to be clear it sounds like the
scope is simply a project
timeline in which certain um
events or things will take place in all
the
parties involved are on the same page so
to speak
and on the same timeline exactly exactly
and it doesn't really involve it's
it's separate from when you talk about
building codes in the building
inspectors
this is a different area thank you
thank you uh before we go on let me just
say this
of those who have signed in on this bill
30th have
signed that they supported two opposed
and one is neutral
all right i do believe that's the last
person testifying on section one
let's move on to section two um
and we're going to have senator perkins
walker introduce section two
welcome senator uh thank you very much
chairman
and committee members for the record i
am senator rebecca perkins coca from
senate district 21
representing the city of portsmouth and
the town of bradbury lead durham
newington new market and newfields i'm
the prime sponsor part two of sb 86
fn which re-establishes the new
hampshire housing and conservation
planning program
to assist municipalities in working
towards zoning goals and planning for
affordable housing in our communities
we all know that housing the housing
crisis is urgent
and well documented the ability of our
state economy to survive and thrive into
the next generation depends on having
that generation
here to take over accounting practices
and dental practices to serve on civic
boards and to add vitality to our life
as a state
that said there is so little we can do
at the state level to affect housing
policy
facilities and their local ordinances
have the most control over where
and how housing can be built and most if
not all of us would agree that this is
how it should work
the hcc cpp does not seek to change that
it is a resource and tool for
municipalities who we all know are
struggling and
we all wish to support with the tools
they need to achieve their
self-identified goals
hcpp is a four-phase program which
municipalities
voluntarily apply for to aid cities and
towns and working towards their zoning
goals for their communities
we all value new hampshire's beautiful
outdoors and want to see the
conservation of such spaces balanced
with housing
that is what hcpp seeks to support
there is no funding request being made
at this time in the bill
part two will simply return hcpp
hcpp to statute and allow rulemaking to
take place
i've worked with the new hampshire
municipal association the new hampshire
housing finance authority the new
hampshire
preservation alliance on this bill and
all are in support of part two
we have also added the new hampshire
association of realtors by amendment to
the program
it grows out of a long history of
collaboration that goes back as far as
2007-2008 known as the growth
growth and development roundtable which
brought together stakeholders from
various industries
developers conservation municipalities
and others and was a very popular
program
unfortunately the hcpp got wrapped up in
tough budget decisions around the great
recession and was removed from statute
this bill represents the main
recommendation of senator fuller clark's
sb 43 commission last year
studying recommendations on how to
address our urgent housing crisis
mr chairman thank you for the
opportunity to present part two and i
would be happy to answer any questions
you may have
thank you senator and may i use this
opportunity to ask that
those of you who have written testimony
could you please send it
to the committee so that we have access
to that as we consider
the exact portion of the process
that will happen next week having your
testimony degree
helps refresh our memories so thank you
very much
uh who else would like to speak to
section 2
of senate bill 86 anybody on the
committee yes
representative may i ask the senator yes
thank you thank you mr chair and thank
you senator for taking
my question this
commission reminds me
of the um section of
house bill 58 i think it was 586 the
housing
bill that we worked on earlier in the
year this looks
sort of like the housing champion kind
of
organization is that am i right in that
or is it less powerful than that or
about the same in terms of helping
communities and allowing them
doesn't have any money attached is that
right
yeah thank you very much representative
there are similarities
in that um you know both would be
completely voluntary for
our towns and cities to participate in
at this time there's no
request for funding to support this
program but
um this would be it's a separate
standalone program where towns and
cities could apply
at each of the four phases um for
for grants for planning assistance and
just consultation on
how to amend their zoning so it's
similar in a way that
um all it does is basically provide
incentives or or
tools to our municipalities to support
how they look at housing in their own
community so yeah similarities thank you
thank you any other questions yes
representative
thank you mr chairman for taking right
now question
senator
my question is i'm not clear on the
funding here that there is no fiscal
analysis and you noted that and that
it's not clear to me
as to why because
this will have a fiscal impact so
why do we have no analysis on that
sure and thank you very much
representative for the questions so
recognizing that um this this year and
coming into this biennial budget was
certainly an
unprecedented situation in our state um
all we are asking for right now is
for this program language simply to be
returned
to statute so in the future
to implement and effectualize the
program you're correct we obviously will
need to make a budget ask and to provide
potentially staff you know to support
the program or at least part of an fte
but um knowing that there's many other
competing priorities this year
we're simply asking for the statutory
language to be returned and we can
have that discussion another day
any other questions for the senator
about section two
there are two hands up mr chair the
first representative gilman and the
second from representative
uh thank you mr chair and thank you
senator perkins cuoco for taking my
question
um i have uh my question is about the
section uh about what's available
uh where is it what can be awarded for
the matching grants
and number four is uh mapping historic
structures and buildings within
communities mm-hmm um
do you are you aware of certified local
governments
they're very a program that's managed by
the division of historic resources and
handles federal grants for doing just
that kind of thing
so my question my question is can a
certified local government
go for mapping historic structures
with both kinds of grants both a federal
and a and
uh state that is an
excellent technical question
representative and i appreciate you
asking it i
am going to respectfully uh defer to ben
frass
from new hampshire housing who i believe
is also on here to address that and if
he can't i will make sure to follow up
with you with the answer to that
okay thank you very much thank you
there any other oh we have mr frost
you going to uh speak for this ben press
good morning mr chairman and uh yeah yes
uh
representative lee oh i'm sorry uh
mr frost could you just hold from minute
i forgot i recognized
i represented
go ahead representative you're up thank
you mr chair for taking uh
letting me ask the question uh senator
perkins quaker this is this is more like
an
enabling legislation or the policy
correct without the fiscal note so
we can deal with the housing crisis and
enable the local communities to make
that determination
that's correct representative and thank
you for the question
yes this is very much enabling because
it essentially just puts language back
into the rsa in the future we can
implement the program as mentioned
earlier with with budget requests or
funding
and then once that those steps are taken
this is a voluntary program where towns
and cities can reach out
if they would like assistance with goals
that they've identified for themselves
in terms of housing
yeah just to follow up mr chair please
go ahead
so this is more like a opt-in opt-out
by the local communities so it is
what the local communities can do to
address their housing crisis correct
very much so representative and there is
um
language in here in multiple places that
references the voluntary nature of this
program and that
it's completely optional if
municipalities choose to participate or
not
okay thank you uh next will be mr frost
and then representative tripp
thank you mr chairman this is ben frost
i'm the managing
director of policy and public affairs
for new hampshire housing
and i'll speak just to address
representative gilman's question
initially and i can proceed with further
testimony if you wish but
representative gilman you asked about
certified local governments
and whether a municipality would be able
to use
the federal grants to do similar work to
what is enabled in
the housing and conservation planning
program with regard to historic
resources and i think the answer is yes
although i would say that the in all
likelihood
a municipality that is a certified local
government
probably already would have done that
work that is
envisioned in that particular section of
the housing and conservation planning
program
but if there were funds available for a
community to
become a certified local government
for purposes of historic resources
preservation
then they certainly should be able to
use both the state and
federal resources available to them
thank you representative
i'll eat yourself first
thank you for taking my question thank
you uh senator perkins coca for
uh concerning my question uh
i have a question about uh there's a
there's a provision for multiple
municipalities uh
embarking on uh this type of uh program
what would happen if uh after
phase two that uh uh one or more of the
municipalities decided that uh they were
not
uh going to pursue uh subsequent faces
sure thank you for the question
representative um
as stated you know this is a completely
voluntary program and so it's really
it's just here to help and provide
support to municipalities
i am again going to ask ben frost to
chime in as he's had much more history
with the operations of the program but
um as i understand it i would presume
the answer to that to be
that the municipalities which wish to
continue
would simply submit a new application um
without the town that wanted to drop out
okay thank you any anyone else
wish to speak to section two or the
question uh
the senator
mr chad we get one other hand that was
up from injury
andrew yaros who's from the conservation
law
uh wait i think he's speaking to two but
i could be wrong
mr yarrow is it did you wish to speak
yes i do thank you thank you very much
um mr chairman and committee members and
thank you for the opportunity to speak
on this bill
my name is andrew yaros and i'm a legal
fellow at the conservation law
foundation
a non-profit environmental advocacy
organization that works to support the
environment
and healthy communities in new hampshire
and throughout new england
i'm here to speak in strong support of
part two of senate bill 86 creating the
housing and conservation
planning program we've also submitted
written testimony that provides
additional background information
as mentioned this program would provide
technical assistance matching grants to
municipalities as they strategically
develop and implement plans to create
much needed housing and preserve open
space
right now high demand and low inventory
in both the home buying and rental
markets have caused prices
to rise beyond the reach of many
residents even as household incomes have
risen
new hampshire needs to develop tens of
thousands of additional housing units to
meet demand
the housing and conservation planning
program would help alleviate these
issues by encouraging municipalities to
add higher density
and workforce housing in an efficient
manner balancing development with the
protection of natural resources
this can create neighborhoods that offer
potential access to jobs transportation
green space housing stability and
economic opportunity
the program would also require
municipalities to engage with
stakeholders in the development and
planning stages
which will help ensure that the policies
are equitable and reflect
community needs again we strongly
support and urge you to vote ought to
pass on sb 86 part two
thank you for your time and i'm happy to
answer any questions
are there any questions for mr yaros
seeing gun uh is there anyone else who
would like to speak to section
two mr chairman this is ben frost i i do
have further testimony if i may
yes please go ahead thank you mr
chairman
again ben frost from new hampshire
housing um i i want to
emphasize a couple things and
representative manjapudi
uh pointed out the the state's housing
crisis and that that
is an important target
of this legislation although recognize
that the original legislation
was at a different time at a time when
we were also facing
serious housing affordability problems
in the state but it should not be lost
on the committee
that this is in fact um a a
enabling legislation that looks at both
housing
and conservation uh so this is in
an attempt to get communities
that want to participate in this
voluntarily
to look at the same time at their
housing issues
and their natural resource conservation
issues and their historic
resource preservation issues and in fact
that is
the design of it that they they can't
choose
one or the other we're just going to
look at housing we're just going to look
at natural resource preservation
under the the precepts of this program
as it is organized and designed
and conceived municipalities need to do
both
at the same time we recognize that
you know there are really important
conservation concerns
ranging from wildlife habitat to
subsurface water
quality that are threatened
frankly by certain types of development
and the the what is being encouraged
here
is a a type of development
that will at the same time help us meet
our housing objectives but also to
conserve important natural resources
again strictly voluntary and
and strongly encourage the committee's
consideration of this legislation
i'd be happy to take any questions any
questions for mr
trump
seeing that is there anyone from the
public that would ask like to ask
questions
frost or anything on section two there
are two hands up mr chair
uh in order it was sarah holland for the
new hampshire association of realtors
the second
was tom jerosa from the
housing action here both it i believe
both for section two
okay uh miss holland would you like to
speak to section two
good morning thank you um so my name is
sarah holland i am
the broker and owner of sarah holland
and company a real estate firm in
plymouth and i'm also the vice chair
of the public policy committee at the
new hampshire association of realtors
um we're here to support all three
sections of senate bill 86 but specific
to
section two we definitely echo mr frost
um land in new hampshire is finite and
we need to have a better understanding
of how it is being utilized
it is enabling legislation so it doesn't
mandate a community to do
anything hopefully it will eventually
provide the resources to our
municipalities to protect our natural
resources
while ensuring more housing options for
our residents
um and decisions made this is an
important point that
decisions made in one community have
consequences in neighboring communities
so this may be a way for us to better
understand those impacts
um thank you and that those are all our
thoughts on section two
any questions for miss holland
mr johnston from nhma do you have
comments on section two
yes um cordell johnston representing the
new hampshire municipal association
and all i'll say is that we support uh
section two
i can't really add much to what ben
frost and
uh senator perkins quoga have said so
i'll just say we support it and leave it
at that
thank you thank you and we have mr
darosa online
to speak to this yes i did see uh also
representative benjami's hand
went up also after uh mr derosa
okay so mr jerosa we'll take you next
and then representative mentioned
thank you and good morning mr chairman
and members of the committee for the
record my name is tom derose i serve as
communications and engagement manager of
housing action new hampshire we are a
statewide coalition of 80 organizations
united around affordable housing policy
we're in support of sb 86 part 2
established in the new hampshire housing
conservation planning program
it won't add much to what has already
been said other than to say that we are
aware
and this committee's aware of the
affordable housing crisis that this
state faces
as has been noted this is just another
tool in the toolbox that we can work to
give communities
that they can use to address this
shortage um and then
again you know as we know it's unfunded
uh for now but
it will remind municipalities that
increasing affordable housing does not
mean
compromising our beautiful natural
landscape or rural character
the support and technical assistance for
the comprehensive approach can help
increase our housing needs while
balancing all the other interests uh
similar to what mr frost had already
mentioned
so just in conclusion we we would say
that that this advisory group is simply
advisory and the real opportunity lies
with
municipalities that are interested in
providing housing for its residents
while balancing the importance of
conservation
thank you thank you any questions
generated from that testimony yes mr
powell
thank you mr chairman my question
pertains to
um page 2
line 27 with reference to
third-party technical assistance
providers is this from mr derosa
okay i think he can answer this all
right i just i i
took you out of order uh because i have
president
[Music]
thank you mr chair my question is to all
three ben frost
andrew yaros and sarah holland
how does this enabling legislation
help with the new hampshire communities
that have
old mill buildings that are dilapidated
and if we can rehab them and make them
into
housing units without
increasing the carbon footprint by
demolishing
would that do you see any
uh help to the communities to rehab
these
and make them affordable housing
mr chairman this is ben frost i could
address that if you wish yes please
uh thank you representative manager puti
for that question um
in fact you point out one of the
greatest assets
many of our communities have that is the
existing built
infrastructure that is historically
present and where the commercial centers
of our communities
indeed these are oftentimes great
opportunities
for redevelopment not for commercial
purposes but for residential purposes
and we've seen this across the state uh
from one community to the next a lot of
this
is happening in places like manchester
and nashua
dover and and these often times are done
uh in a way that's you know is really
sensitive to the their surroundings
and if you look at in particular i'll
call it in
one project in particular in nashua um
john stabile uh redid the the cotton
mill
which was a derelict building in a
really down and out section of the city
and
when when he took on that project and it
was a multi-year
project for him one of the largest
projects he's engaged in
it served as an anchor for redevelopment
of that portion of the city of nashua
and is providing a significant number of
both market rate rental units and uh
affordable subsidized uh units for
people who
are of lower income these are great
opportunities
uh for for redevelopment and in a way
that's you know
consistent with uh the history of our
communities
thank you mr frost any other questions
representative tripp
i need on youtube
thank you for taking my question now i
have a question for uh
ben frost uh in phase two
this is going to be the development of a
growth and development
uh strategy now who exactly would be on
the board
or organization that's doing this do you
have any uh
uh thoughts on this thank you for that
question
representative trippy uh the strategies
are to be developed by the
municipalities themselves
so if a municipality wants to engage in
this work
they they would um essentially apply to
well if now it's the office of strategic
initiatives but
recognizing that the current budget
as it is presently in the senate would
move the planning division over to the
department of business and economic
affairs and this program would follow
i presume the planning division there so
you know assuming uh if
the legislature in a future year chooses
to appropriate money to do this
uh then a municipality would apply to do
apply to for funding to do so they would
provide their own matching funds
and then they would hire a consultant to
help them so it's really
the consultant working for the
municipality
uh that is engaged in this work so the
municipality is driving this whether it
is the
local board of selectmen or the planning
board or some committee that's assembled
by the municipality this is
a municipally focused and municipally
driven uh
program thank you
if there are no more questions i'm going
to move on to section 3 bill
are there any questions for section 2
seeing none i'm going to go to section 3
and do we have a member of the senate
who would like me to do section three
did not mr chair we have senator morse
who should be
available to speak president of the
senate we're honored by your presence uh
sir and uh
it's flora jewish mr chair can you hear
me
yes thank you mr chair and members of
the committee
for the record i am senate senator chuck
mois i represent senate district 22
which includes the towns of salem
atkinson
plaistow and pelham this morning i am
pleased to introduce part three of
senate bill 86
this is relative to prohibiting the
installation of certain commercially
available heating systems and engaging
the services of certain energy providers
the bill is straightforward and very
pro-consumer
it supports citizens being able to
choose how they want to heat their homes
and their businesses
it prevents any political subdivision of
the state
or any local land use board from
adopting any measures that prohibit or
restrict
a person or a business's choice when it
comes to their heating system or their
energy providers
new hampshire citizens should have the
right to choose any reliable energy
system
that best suits their needs whether it's
gas
electricity solar geothermal
oil or any other source i know there are
a few folks wishing to testify
that can get into the details so i think
most of your questions about this bill
would be best answered by them but i
would still
be happy to answer any questions the
committee has
any questions for the president of the
senate yes senator
representative thank you mr chair and
thank you senator morris
um is there
has there been a history of um
communities prohibiting
people from installing the heating
system of their choice in the state
that i'm that you're aware of no and i
think that's what you'll hear testimony
after
myself that we uh we basically want to
make sure that that doesn't happen i
mean if you just think about
um your local oil or propane deal is the
investments that they have
into their companies i think they're
nervous and they
certainly uh looked out to us to try and
put in legislation
so that they you know they could make
investments comfortably
in vehicles and plants and everything
else
to uh you know keep their businesses
going forever
thank you thank you senator
um this is sort of related but a little
bit unrelated
i'm wondering about i've lived in three
four different houses that i've my
family has installed a wood stove
into and the source of my
heating would be the man who cut the
lumber
the timber and delivered the boards of
wood to my home
are those kinds of things covered
is that considered a safe i'm i'm just i
guess i'm curious about what
what would be prevented from being
prohibited
yeah i i think what we're trying to do
and i don't know that it directly
speaks to wood but um it basically is
letting you make that choice
and the uh i'm certain when it comes to
wood in the state of new hampshire
being used as a heating source um we
we would want to protect that in new
hampshire
representative gallagher
um so um
yeah um so since we discussed
um the whole germanis question with
um senate bill 84 i kind of want to
bring that up again here
um i i mean i can see the connection
between the first two parts pretty
easily since they're both about
planning boards um or
about planning and housing and
construction that sort of stuff but and
this one
seems more about energy policy and um
i'm just wondering if you could draw the
connection a bit more clearly for me
well i mean to be honest with you the
whole bill now
is jermaine coming out of the senate so
the reality of the house looking at it
there's
several subject matters in here that um
you know would cover your germain this
rules um
if the speaker thought any different i'm
sure he'd let me know
but um i think the omnibus bills are
difficult for the house and difficult
for the senate
and um we uh if all the legislators had
listened and
only dealt with bills that dealt with
covet or dealt with the budget
um i don't think we'd be doing these
omnibus bills because they're difficult
for the senate too
but the reality of it being um related
this whole bill is a bill and that's how
it was sent
over to the house so i think it's it's
germaine as a bill
are there any other questions for
senator morris
will we move on
representative we have anybody in cube
no
no no mr chair all right i thought i
just saw a hand walk in the room
yes for him thank you mr
senator moore said would it be fair to
say that
we've been talking about this before on
a personal basis built somebody building
a home
but wouldn't that wouldn't this bill in
fact uh
protect uh any builders uh
who were putting in a commercial uh
facility or commercial uh project
so that they also would be protected
and would help us in the long term
protect our developers
providing jobs for the state
well it specifically says businesses
have choices too
in the legislation but the um i think
the reality of it is
um you know as technology changes and
and people are making new construction
um
they're gonna look to different areas
but um we still
have a whole state that operated
operates on
things like propane and oil and we
certainly have a lot of local neighbors
that own businesses
and and we just don't want to see them
zoned out in new hampshire
and that's why we wrote this legislation
thank you
a question from representative davis for
the senator
thank you mr chair and um thank you for
taking my question
um this is just a wording thing but on
the last on page six
paragraphs five b and six appear to be
the same
can you explain am i just missing
something or
are they repeated for a reason
i think she's on line one on page six
i'm looking at sections 5b and
section 6 on page 6.
i think it's because it's addressing two
parts of the law
um and i think the people speaking after
me can speak to that but it looks like
it's addressing um from the page before
one section um rsa 155 and then
in two it looks like it's addressing rsa
674 so that's probably why it's repeated
okay thank you thank you man and uh
corel johnson did you have a comment on
that
foreign section three
uh yes uh thank you mr chairman cordell
johnston representing the new hampshire
municipal association
um and just uh on that last question
yes uh that's correct uh
one of those paragraphs is
making an amendment to the building code
uh
statute and the other is making a
parallel amendment to the
zoning zoning statute
we generally get nervous when whenever
there's a
an attempt to uh restrict local
authority
uh over over zoning matters
um but as far as i know
as indicated no municipality has
has expressed any interest
in enacting these kinds of restrictions
so i'm not sure
that there is a significant concern
from the um from the municipal
association
i think you may hear concerns uh from
building of building officials and i
would defer to them about any concerns
they may have on on this section
and that's all i have for you thank you
other
uh yes representative thank you mr chair
thank you mr johnson for taking
this question i'm just curious is
under our municipalities currently
allowed
to make these kind of restrictions and i
know that they can't do anything
that we unless we let them
under our current statutes are they
allowed to
restrict this and
something like this i yeah i i think
theoretically they could
as i say i i don't uh believe any
municipality has but
theoretically they could okay thank you
are there
any other questions and sections for yes
that representative powell
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
johnston for taking my question
the language in this bill specifically
refers to heating or other energy
systems could you please clarify what
energy systems
are and i would like to know if that
encompasses cooking such as
ovens and stoves as well as hvac systems
mr chairman this is senator morris the
are
you all set with me with questions yes
thank you senator i appreciate you being
here okay
thank you uh yes uh representative power
to answer your question
um certainly it would include hvac
and i would think that it would include
uh
cooking as well uh i'm i guess i'm not
sure whether that's the intent
uh i wasn't involved in drafting it but
i
uh i i would read it as including
uh the things that you mention
thank you i believe also includes
watergate right
are there more questions for section
three or about section three we have a
lot of members of the public who have
signed up to speak
who do we have in cube we have three
members from the
municipal county government in order of
representative andrew pudi
gallagher and then in queue we have from
the new yorker building officials
association
uh william mckinney who signed up to
speak on
this final section why don't we start
off with representative matthew fuji
thank you mr chair thank you mr cordell
johnson for taking my question would
this
be creating micromanagement
for the local municipalities or taking
away
local control if you're going down to
cooking and gas grills
to you know grilling in the backyard
we're gonna regulate isn't that
is it am i seeing it too
um broadly or is
is that the way it reads
um it cert it certainly is taking
authority away
uh and whether i i guess whether you
consider it micromanaging
is um is a matter of perspective
uh we we we do like to avoid
state micromanagement of
of local government a few years ago
the legislature put in something that
said you can't require
sprinklers in that municipalities can't
require sprinklers
in certain buildings uh and so
you know when the legislature finds
something that it doesn't want
municipalities to regulate
um it uh it does it
and as i said we try to we try to avoid
that
um i guess it's really a judgment call
for you whether this is a policy that
you think is
is worthwhile
yes representative gallagher you're up
next
uh i i believe um representative fan was
up next but
i guess since i'm speaking i'll um do my
question
anyways um so yeah for mr
johnson so you said that um since
no municipalities currently
implement such a regulation that
therefore
no the municipalities don't have any
sorts of
concerns about this legislation but
put another way couldn't the fact that
um no municipalities implement such
regulation also mean
that it's not really necessary either
yeah that's that certainly is uh you
certainly could
certainly could look at it that way and
just to be clear we're
we i i'm not here supporting uh section
three
um i i expressed mild concerns about it
in the senate but they went
but they they did pass it uh and
i'm not here begging you not not to
adopt section 3 either
just kind of providing information but
yeah you're right um
if if no one's doing it you could
interpret that to mean
that that it's not necessary
representative
[Music]
thank you mr chair uh thank you mr
johnson okay so apparently i have this
backwards
i understood that this bill said that
towns cannot enact um an ordinance
saying
you can't have uh any a particular kind
of heating
is that in fact what it does say
are we trying to stop them from doing a
thing or are we trying to make them do a
thing
i think i think you're you're trying to
stop
them from stopping others
so i am correct so am i correct
that really the basis of this bill is
to prevent an area a jurisdiction we'll
call it
from enacting an ordinance that
prohibits
burning fossil fuels for heating
is that what we're doing yes if the town
of peterborough
say adopted an ordinance uh saying that
all new construction
must be heated by solar uh
wind uh geothermal and and
cannot use fossil fuels this would
this would that's what this bill is
trying to
stop that would say you you can't impose
that regulation
okay thank you very much i now know what
i think i actually think local
jurisdictions should be able to do that
if we're serious about climate change
thank you so much for making that clear
to me you're welcome uh
and we had remember the public uh center
yes mr chair
uh we have mr william
mckinney from the new hampshire uh
building officials association
mr mckinney you're uh yes good morning
and thank you mr chair and members of
the committee
i am william mccain before you get too
deep into this you had
asked for a budget of 10 minutes to give
your remarks i'm going to ask you
to ratchet that down to two to three
minutes
understood i will do so
thank you i'm william mckinney i'm the
president of the new hampshire building
officials association
if you're not familiar with our
association we are
a professional organization with members
of building building code fire code
officials
architects engineers mechanical
professionals
contractors so our primary focus is to
provide training
to all of those members
and to keep up to date on state law and
the statutes that affect the
construction industry
our primary concern with part three
of this bill is that it amends
[Music]
rsa 155a and specifically rf8
rsa155a2 which is
the state building code um our
biggest concern with this is not that we
object to the language
is that we don't see anywhere on here
that the building code review
board established under rsa 155 a10
has provided any input or as even
[Music]
aware of this amendment
being that we have some strong concerns
that this amendment could possibly
create some conflicts
uh to the current state building code
specifically the international
building code the international
residential code and the international
mechanical code all of those govern
heating systems in any of our buildings
i will state that i think the building
code review board has done an excellent
job in the years
of trying to keep up to date with
newer technologies in to be specific
um most recently they adopted amendments
me 15 13 18 and me 15 14
18 which both allow for
systems that you would find meeting
european standards
provided that they have some
additions to that they have to provide
all of their data and data labels in
english
and they have to have fittings that
comply with north american standards
but they've also gone through to amend
the mechanical code to recognize
biomass fuels as well so i really feel
that rather than having language like
this in
legislation that it should be through
amendment
by the building code review board um
that would adopt
and allow for any of those systems in
there i do understand the concerns
of you know local locality or local
communities
restricting certain heating fuels and um
we certainly would not like to see that
we certainly want to see you know our
efforts put to more energy efficient and
more greener energies
but we have to recognize that you know
those are those fuels are out there
and technology has come a long way to
make those more economical
um and with that i would just summarize
that
our significant issue with part three
is that it has not had the input from
the building code review board
that is a board that was appointed by
the legislature
to review and recommend any amendments
to the state building code
and we believe they should have input on
this before it moves forward
thank you mr chair and i will entertain
any questions thank you mr mckay are
there any questions for mr mckinney
[Music]
chair okay uh taking in order uh
charlie ermer and leslie anderson
in that board and i apologize they just
popped up so i haven't looked to see if
they are on our list of where they may
be from
no i don't see either one of them on our
list speakers
oh leslie anderson did you say leslie
anderson i did
let's take her first she's she is on our
list of
guest speakers so mrs anderson you're up
and uh
please try to limit your comments to two
to three minutes
thank you chairman dolan can you hear me
yes
uh thank you for for allowing me to
speak um we did have registered also
ryan jackson
charlie irmer and uh jason grower
yes i heard brian jackson okay
and jason growler yes and charlie armor
yes we have all
all three of them okay
and thank you and also don shagnan um
testify as well
um i just i wanted to uh thank you for
letting me testify today my name is
leslie anderson i'm the president and
ceo of the propane gas
association of new england we're a
regional alternative energy association
across six states
and we represent over 40 propane
businesses in new hampshire
many are locally owned and many are
smithers
over 2 700 employees work in new
hampshire in our industry
supplying clean reliable energy to over
7 500 residential homes
and i'm speaking in support of part
three which deals specifically with
consumer choice as it pertains to how
consumers decide to heat their homes
uh nothing in this bill would prohibit
the state fire marshal or the mechanical
boards from regulating
any of the fuels as they currently are
to make sure that they're safe to make
sure that they're clean
this would just allow individual
consumers to decide which energy they
choose
to heat their home they would still have
to do so in accordance
with the state rules that are governed
by the state
agencies i consider myself an
environmentalist
i have a master's degree in
environmental management i'm an attorney
and i have worked as the bureau director
for the maine department of
environmental management
and as an environmentalist i am very
troubled by the electrify everything
movement that is gaining momentum across
our state
and i'm deeply concerned about the lack
of energy diversity and energy security
that's inherent in this electricity only
scheme
propane is unfortunately lumped into
fossil fuels and given a bad
wrap we are a beneficial byproduct
that's left over
there is more propane produced than is
used every year
if you don't use propane to offset an
energy source it's simply burned off
so if you believe in reduce reuse
recycling you should be promoting
propane as an energy source
rather than just having it burned
unnecessarily and not used
and here in new hampshire natural gas
supplies 19
of our electricity each year and propane
is a byproduct of natural gas
so if we're going to be good
environmental stewards and reduce
our environmental footprints we should
be promoting propane
propane is also the unsung hero of
extreme weather events
if climate change is increasing and the
likelihood of these prevents is
predicted to increase we need to make
sure new hampshire has a healthy vibrant
propane
industry to step in and provide energy
diversity and security during
emergencies
just look at covid19 for the most recent
examples
we were the primary energy source used
for heat outdoor testing sites
including to let workers into lonza in
newington new hampshire where they're
currently developing and manufacturing
the modern event coronavirus vaccine
we are also were used for hot water for
hand washing stations and hot showers
for
the homeless in new hampshire as well as
a sort of
of outdoor heating for businesses
including numerous restaurants who are
using propane today so they can have
customers eat outside
and for all the testing sites that were
set up outside of hospitals throughout
the state
our industry is very concerned about the
environment and we're actively working
to reduce carbon emissions
we've reduced millions of tons of carbon
emissions each year across the globe
by being used to offset the world's
greatest health threat
which is indoor air pollution caused by
burning wood and cooking and heating
in many of the countries across the
globe over 3.5 million people each year
die from indoor air pollution and
burning wood
also leads to just deforestation and
alarming rate
in developing countries and it causes
enormous carbon dioxide emissions
moving one family from wood to propane
saves over a ton
of carbon dioxide a year and when we
move 50 families
in parts along the equator from wood to
propane we save an acre of rainforest
land which is so
important for the ecological and the
climate benefits that it has
so i do believe that environmental
environments should really look at
propane as part of the solution in new
hampshire
and i also think that citizens deserve
the right to use their own clean energy
source
and depict what they want to use this
does not prohibit anyone from putting
solar panels
or electric heat pumps into their houses
if they want to but it also allows them
to have clean warm air furnaces for
propane
that would provide clean heating for
them or other fuels
you know if they choose to to burn wood
or to burn
other things that are approved and
allowed for
use through the new hampshire agencies
that regulate them
so i ask for your support for part three
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
that you have
any questions for ms anderson
okay now let's move on to charlie emmer
irma
yes good morning can you hear me yes all
right good morning my name is charlie
armor
and i'd like to thank chairman dolan and
members of the committee for allowing me
to speak today
and to ask for your support of part
three of senate bill 86
this bill will ensure that new hampshire
citizens have the right to choose
whatever energy source that they want
i'm a lifelong resident of new hampshire
growing up in derry and now living in
salem i'm also the vice president
of polar gas and oil which is located in
atkinson new hampshire
and also the current chairman of the
propane gas association
of new england the company i represent
is a family business and we've been
around for 89 years
and provides propane and service to
thousands of homes and businesses
in new hampshire mass and maine and our
customers depend on us
on propane for many things including hot
showers heating their homes
drying their laundry cooking hot meals
and running their generators when
there's no power
if this bill does not pass and local
jurisdictions put restrictions
on what consumers can only choose for
their energy source
and thus eliminating propane which is a
staple in our community
it would be a cause it would be costly
for consumers to have to convert
their existing systems installed in
their homes or businesses
it takes away the consumer's choice and
ultimately will increase the cost of
energy
because of less competition the impact
us personally for as an employer
would be a loss of over a hundred jobs
which ultimately affects entire families
that make a good
living here in the state and many homes
and essential businesses would be in the
dark during storms
whether it's a winter storm a hurricane
or any other
this would put essential personnel in
harm's way including those
including those that need to be on life
support
hospitals and municipalities including
police and fire buildings that rely on
power
so for these reasons i would like to ask
for your support in
of part three of senate bill 86 so we
can give consumers the right to choose
whatever energy source they want for
their family and i thank you for your
time this morning
thank you mr any questions for mr irma
from farmer
saying that let's upload my richard
tripp representative tripp do you have a
question
let me unmute so that i can you can be
heard i can be heard
uh mr palmer mr ermer yes uh
do you think that uh uh a local
municipality
uh restricting uh
energy systems to electricity only would
would increase the the cost of housing
and and heating
in new hampshire i do especially if they
have to retrofit
um and you know it's changing out in
complete systems
so yes i have a second question
sure okay uh
what effect do you think uh restricting
energy systems on uh housing development
would be in new hampshire
um so i would have to defer that your
question to leslie anderson who just
recently spoke
to give you the the statistics
uh mr anderson are you still on the line
i am on the line could you just repeat
that portion of the question
uh what do you think the effect on uh
housing development particularly uh
workforce housing
uh would restricting energy systems
uh in towns and cities have
well i can give you an example you know
there's been several
um housing developments and and
apartment buildings in vermont that have
gone
in and they have gone in and been
required to have electricity only
and um some of these buildings have not
heated up above 50 degrees in the winter
time
with the heat pump technology that's out
there and
it it heat pumps you know are great for
the shoulder months but when you get
into
temperatures below 20 degrees they do
not really heat the houses the way that
you need them to
and propane provides an affordable
alternative
uh during our cold months that allows
poor people to to be able to heat more
efficiently
and with less of a carbon impact when
it's very cold than you would with
electricity
because electricity loses a lot of
energy in its transportation and when it
gets really cold
all of the electricity has in that's
made in new england has to switch over
to oil
or to coal because natural gas that's
used for it is not available
it goes to the consumers in residential
locations when we have big energy demand
so in the coldest parts of the months if
you're heating with just electricity
you're really
being fueled by oil most of that time
so from an environmental justice
standpoint i think it's more
economical and to the benefit of those
people who
are not as advantaged as others to be
able to
have a diversity in their energy sources
to keep their costs low
thank you mr shaggy are you
[Music]
available to make a comment
i am chairman uh can you hear me
yes so right ahead okay uh first i'd
like to thank you for allowing me to
speak uh
in regards to senate bill 86 and in
particular
my support of part three i have
submitted some written testimonies so
i'm i'm going to take a very short
period of time to
help you with your time crunch here but
i i do want to reiterate that
you know this this movement to
electrical
uh heat source is uh is
really leading us down a very bad path
um just go back to 2008 ice storm in new
hampshire
when uh for over 434 000 homes were
without
electricity for up to 13 days according
to the puc
if those are all electrically heated
homes i think you'd have a lot of
constituents
dying and very unhappy with ones that
that survive it
propane's a great alternative it's also
one of the products that is considered
an alternative fuel under the u.s
environmental protection agency's clean
air act
and freedom of choice you know being
born and raised in the state of new
hampshire
i know freedom of choice isn't just the
american way but in new hampshire it's
the
where it's it's through and through the
uh the american way
they do not want to be told what they
can do or when they can do it
and we have had a lot of problems with
heat pump technology
as uh was brought up by ms anderson
in not just vermont but maine and and in
new hampshire where
when it gets extremely cold which we do
get up here
they will not heat homes to a
comfortable level
um so i for those reasons
and other reasons such as the
availability of it in emergency
where it's being used continuously
when electricity fails
we cannot be banning products and
providing a secure
safe environment for the residents of
new hampshire
so i would hope that you would support
sb 86.
thank you uh any other members of the
public uh
mr grower or mr jackson
that ms anderson had uh alluded to that
you want to testify
are either of them online they are mr
grower
mr growers should be good to go and
mr jackson should be available also and
then we have
three other members of the public mr
chair after that okay mr brewer
hi chairman dolan good morning to you
this is jason brauer can you hear me
okay
yes great well i just want to say very
briefly uh thank you very much for the
opportunity
to testify unlike the previous speakers
i'm not a native new hampshirite
i was born in new york i went on to
spend about 24 years serving in the navy
and then finally settled down here and
called new hampshire home now where we
both live
my wife and i live in goffstown so again
thanks very much for the opportunity
i'll keep my remarks brief
i've submitted a written copy of my
testimony for reference uh but i just
want to hit a couple of points that
haven't been uh
been discussed here before so my company
i'm the regional director for dead river
off dead river company
uh my responsibilities are delivering
energy to thousands of our customers and
your constituents throughout the state
and we also provide service to home
heating systems as well
so we employ here in the state over 250
people
throughout new england we employ just
over 1200 and so
one of the critical things that like the
community consider is that if this
doesn't pass
one of the side effects could be that
you know companies like mine and the
others who are testifying today
we could just be legislated out of
existence and so
that's bad for our company of course but
that's hundreds of people that we employ
here and so
i just think that as our nation recovers
from the from the effects of covet of
the coveted pandemic
we can't afford to pick which companies
should be winners and which should be
losers
i'd also like to very briefly say that
you know certain types of fuels
uh kind of get a bad rap as far as their
cleanliness
uh but we are making strides as an
industry and i will also say that we
fully support
uh efforts to continually improve our
environment uh propane like you've heard
about
is is a very clean fuel but also heating
oil
in july 2018 a cleaner heating oil was
introduced that effectively eliminated
sulfur so
this ultra low ultra low sulfur heating
oil
really reduces emissions in a
significant way and it also results in
greater heating efficiency
and it opens even more options to
consumers to install the most advanced
ultra efficient equipment when they're
ready to upgrade and so
just as one example i personally did
that last week and so i'll be burning
significantly less
oil to heat my home in the in the
wintertime
just by way of comparison today the
average homeowner uses about 700 gallons
of heating oil annually this is less
than half of their usage in the 80s so
we're making progress and we're not
saying that that it's a perfect solution
but we are getting better uh also
we as a company are taking advantage of
every opportunity to create a cleaner
environment right here in our backyard
uh as we speak my company is pioneering
a new uh renewable liquid fuel called
ethyl avulinate
this fuel can be produced from either a
woody biomass or just
general waste and it's shown significant
promise and
just to put things in perspective our
own employees are testing these fuels in
their own homes so
we do take this very seriously overall
as a company we believe that a broad
spectrum of energy choices is most
beneficial to consumers
and we're really reminded of this during
these these times of natural disasters
like those rolling blackouts in texas
and california and we believe that homes
that have multiple sources of heat and
energy are resilient
so i'll just close the phrase that that
became kind of second nature to us in
the military uh we had a very simple
saying and that is that one is none and
two is one
so uh resilience resilience
sorry yeah one is none and two is one
um anyway i respectfully ask for your
consideration and support for part three
of senate bill 86
uh to ensure that consumers and your
constituents can choose for themselves
which fuels they want to heat their home
thank you mr chairman i look forward to
any questions that you or the committee
may have
thank you mr brown are there any
questions for jason brown
so you know let's uh let's ask ryan
jackson if you'd like to speak
to the kids thank you mr chairman and
thank you committee members
uh ryan jackson here with um the chief
operating officer with dia for shard in
dover new hampshire
also a resident of uh stratford new
hampshire
uh i'm here today speaking in support of
part 3 sb 86
part 3 of the legislative proposal
allows the citizens in new hampshire to
have their choice when it comes to
heating their home throughout the year
including the bitter winter temperatures
that we sometimes experience in our
state
as other states around the country pass
legislation to mandate that the
residents use electric heat pumps to
heat their homes they are not taking
all the variables into account before
making these tough decisions and these
policies do not belong in new hampshire
electric heat pumps work solely off the
power grid
it's important to remember that
electricity must be generated
for it to be consumed we also need to
look at energy plans and policies
from the cradle to the grave how is the
energy generated
how is the energy consumed and how
efficient was this process
the epa's energy star program gives
propane a source site ratio
of 1.01 compared to 2.52 for the
electricity for the new england iso grid
this means that it takes 2.5 units of
electricity to produce and deliver one
unit
of energy to a home compared to 1.01
units for propane
while we do deliver the well we do
believe that electric heat pumps have a
place in the energy portfolio of new
hampshire
we do not believe it should be a mandate
from legislation
a combination of different energy
sources will be the best and it should
remain a decision that is made by the
consumer
i'd like to cite a specific example that
we ran into
in january of 2019 at harmony homes by
the bay an elderly housing facility in
durham new hampshire
they learned firsthand firsthand of the
problems with electric heat pumps being
used for a sole
heat source here in new hampshire the
facility contains around 50 individual
assisted living rooms
when the building was constructed the
engineer had specified that individual
electric heat pumps be installed in
every room to take care of the heating
and cooling needs of that room
when january hit and the temperatures
fell the electric heat pumps could no
longer support the needs of the elderly
residents and they could not get the
building above 65 degrees fahrenheit
electric heat pumps will run at lower
temperatures but they will blow cool air
at best and elderly like hot air not
cool air
the elderly residents at this facility
were not comfortable
and the owner was forced to spend an
additional 70 to
72 thousand dollars to put individual
propane-fired renai heaters in each room
to accommodate the needs of its
residents of which he later recovered in
a lawsuit
the electric heat pumps will work for
the shoulder seasons but should not be
mandated and the only option for heating
homes and businesses within our state
mandating that new hampshire residents
only use electric heat pumps will affect
the livelihood of 40 different propane
companies that are directly involved in
their communities within our state
most of these businesses are small
family-owned businesses
with over a hundred locations throughout
the state to serve their customers
with these small businesses they sustain
over twenty seven hundred green jobs in
the local infrastructure to provide
critical energy
energy diversity and reduce the demand
on our fragile
electrical grid it is for these reasons
that i ask you to support the passes of
part 3 of sb 86 and give our residents
the option to choose the energy choice
that best fits their needs
thank you any questions mr jackson
yes representative stevens has a
question
um thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
[Music]
um
you you'll pardon me it is a bit of a
rhetorical question
but with all the talk of of um
how clean this kind of fuel is
i can speak for my constituents in
lebanon new hampshire
where there is a massive propane storage
facility on state-owned land
that most that according to our fire
chief
poses a blast hazard to our downtown
and our downtown consists of nearly 1200
people
um and several several dozen businesses
what is the propane industry prepared to
do
about the problem of propane storage
across this state
which is far from it doesn't even
resemble
clean energy
mr chair i would defer to leslie
anderson with propane gas associate new
england on that question
leslie you're unmuted so please go ahead
and answer
thank you mr chairman thank you for the
question representative
you know there are dangers with every
type of energy
more people are killed every year from
electrocution than
any incidents that are involved with
propane propane bulk storage facilities
are extremely safe
there's not any instances of
problems with these facilities and we do
have them located
um throughout new england to make sure
that we have reliable propane available
when we have winter storms so that we
can provide the backup energy that's
needed
for generators for elderly for
generators for hospitals
you know you have to have a backup power
when the
electricity goes out in a hospital and a
lot of hospitals turn to
propane there's two 30 000 gallon
propane tanks in augusta maine sitting
right next to the hospital
uh and there's you know not a safety
issue
um with having them there because there
are numerous safety and equipment
protocols built into these systems
and we as an organization for over three
decades have done training with local
fire departments
we offer a free three-day training
tuition for any fire department members
that want to come to our training that
we put on
in both concord and in massachusetts
and at the fire academy in in concord we
do a three-day
every september that fire departments
can come to
we also do training throughout new
hampshire to make sure that our
our product is safe so from a risk
standpoint
and having worked as a risk manager for
over two decades
i would much rather have propane i have
propane in my own home
that i use is my heat and i feel that
it's much safer than
another energy source thank you miss
anderson
we have mark brown available to
speak to the issue speak to this
legislation
yes thank you can you hear me yes
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is mark
brown i'm the executive director of new
england for consumer energy alliance
cea is a nationwide association made up
of both energy consumers and producers
working to advance in all the above
energy environmental policies that will
lower energy costs for every american
cea supports actions that thoughtfully
advance our nation towards a cleaner
more environmentally responsible energy
future
um i won't repeat what others have said
about this being a consumer choice built
but which it clearly is
um but what i'll say is that the
timeliness and importance of the bill
can be
understated unfortunately dozens of
local mandates
and prohibitions have been proposed and
passed across the country
including right next door in
massachusetts that would deny families
and businesses
to choose for themselves how they power
their homes businesses and even what
type of appliances a contractor
can install in a home with bills
it builds excuse me similar bipartisan
legislation to senate bill 86 has passed
in states
like florida kentucky west virginia
georgia among others
to address the aforementioned concerns
further
it's very important that we have one
state uniform energy policy
rather than an unworkable patchwork of
local prohibitions and rules
that would make service and distribution
almost impossible to figure out
i want to reiterate and be clear cea
supports
a clean future with lower emissions
however misguided attempts to ban
natural gas
and propane service by forcing mandates
onto consumers will lead to
higher costs and jeopardize energy
resources that are helping our nation
reduce emissions
um and i want to touch on one thing
about you know what's going on with the
energy transition especially when it
comes to gas
and renewable natural gas you've got
things like green hydrogen
biomethane synthetic methane that are
all going to use pipeline infrastructure
that could heat our homes
so i think it's a little short-sighted
for a municipality to be able to
you know prohibit people from making
choices um
so on behalf of cea i urge you to
support this common sense measure that
will help shield our neighbors from
intrusive and unrealistic mandates
as well as preserve new hampshire's
economic competitiveness
and uh with that i'll be happy to take
any questions
thank you mr brown uh representative
gallagher you have a question for mr
brown
yeah so you're saying that
there were dozens of these mandates
going through municipalities throughout
the country but previously
cartel johnston had testified that none
of them
were that there were no such regulations
in new hampshire so could you just
confirm for me that um
those two are consistent with one
another that none of the
that none of the municipalities you
mentioned were ones in new hampshire
sure no no i don't think there has been
any
prohibitions passed in new hampshire but
i also add that i think it's important
to recognize that you know
allowing one town to
place a prohibition on you know what
type of furnace you could have
could lead to you know that impacting
the ability of another town
you know a neighboring town to have you
know a
natural gas furnace or whatnot so yeah
you are correct
there have been no prohibitions in new
hampshire to my knowledge
thank you um we have uh
bob scully on the line
oh would you like to meet yourself
you're welcome to take the floor
thank you thank you mr chairman members
of the committee i will be brief
um listening to many questions and the
testimony
i am the president of new hampshire
motor transport association and
we have many many dealers of propane and
oil
and this piece of legislation that you
have before you part three very
specifically
came about because of their concern of
what is happening in border states
very much massachusetts and in vermont
and in maine
many of our dealers represent customers
in both
in all those states including new
hampshire so
there is reality out there that their
future is being threatened
and the consumer choice is being taken
away
um a very strong example is in the town
of burlington vermont where not only
are they going through a process right
now with a local community
through the town council has voted to
have all new construction be electric
but they're also mandating that
existing heating sources and homes have
to transition
to electric from their current sources
so this
this is a reality it's a great concern
over 60 percent of the
heating in our state is done by propane
and oil
um so there there is a significant i
think
real based fear that's what happened
what's what excuse me what's happening
in our border states
can creep its way or make its way into
new hampshire so
um i've heard many discussions on the
cleanliness of fuel but from our
perspective
we would like to leave this as a
consumer choice
um and let the consumer decide if they
want to
choose to heat their house with with
anything other than oil or propane
then all all the better for them but um
we would kindly ask your consideration
to
not let what's happened in massachusetts
vermont
and maine happened in new hampshire and
put people's jobs at risk and
companies um they've been around for
decades uh their very existence at risk
so thank you mr chairman
well thank you uh for testifying uh do
we still have
kat burke uh available to speak
yes representative can you hear me okay
yes we're ready today beautiful thank
you very much mr chair and members of
the committee
i apologize for any sign in snafu's on
this bill this morning and appreciate
you giving me the opportunity to speak
very briefly
um for the record my name is kat burke
and i'm the director of government
affairs for unitil
an electric and natural gas distribution
company here in new hampshire
we're here today to voice our support
for part three of this legislation and
just to be clear we are not taking a
position on any other
section of senate bill 86 as many of you
know unitil serves electricity to about
000 customers here in new hampshire and
about 35 000 natural gas customers in
the state as well
we believe that this is a very
straightforward piece of legislation
that simply promotes consumer choice
as many others have spoken to this
morning senator morse
mark brown leslie and others this bill
preserves the right of an individual
customer to connect or utilize
any available utility service or source
of energy desired
to be clear this bill does not seek to
tout the benefits of any particular type
of fuel or energy source
we believe that it's a company that we
can and we should provide energy that's
both affordable and reliable and to that
extent
exercising consumer choice to meet those
goals is a necessity
i'm happy to answer any questions the
committee may have
any questions mr representative
gallagher
uh yeah sorry this was i i meant i meant
for this to go to uh mr scully from
previously
um i was just double checking the um
the testifier sheet and i didn't see him
on there so i
was wondering if he could um just remind
us real quick who he is with
since i missed that certainly
representative gallagher my name is bob
scully
i'm president of the new hampshire motor
transport association the state of new
hampshire
okay thanks thank you and i i believe
mr burke is our last with our last
speaker
um so uh oh we have a question from
representative porter
thank you mr chair i had this question
for a little while now
um we have heard a lot from
the propane gas people but we haven't
heard anything
much from the oil people or the cold
people or the um
solar people or the wind people so i'm
assuming
that they don't have concerns such as
the propane people have
that's a statement of just an
observation but my second part of my
question is this
if a community overwhelmingly
desires
to go net zero for example
75 to 80 percent of the population wants
it
this bill would prohibit them in that
community
from requiring
people to use energy sources that are
net zero
is that correct am i am i reading
my director whoever was up last i guess
maybe uh anderson did you take that
question
you're still on the line
i can take that question as well if miss
anderson has left okay
yeah and i think that that's a very um
representative i think that's a very
difficult policy question you know that
this
legislature and local communities are
faced with right but
um you know the important consideration
is you know whether or not this could
still create this
unworkable collection of local
prohibitions and rules that
you know would make it difficult for
service and distribution to not just one
individual town but you know as mr brown
mentioned perhaps a neighboring town and
whether or not this would you know
create a much
greater cost to consumers you know i
think there are many towns that are
seeking to go towards net zero or to
reach net zero and that is
certainly a an excellent goal um you
know but i think
limiting any source of energy or any
thermal heating source
that would allow a town to reach that
you know might be short-sighted
i believe that's going to be our last
comment on the bill i'm going to close
the hearing
on senate bill 86 and uh
we're about 45 minutes behind but that's
okay we're getting some good public debt
input and that's always
a preferred situation uh i'm gonna
i'm gonna make our our schedule a little
bit worse i'm going to take a
five-minute bio break for those on the
committee i'd ask you to be back here by
11 37.
and uh for those of you in the room or
online the mics are hot
good it's good that you joined us
thank you
[Music]
thank you good to see everybody in real
life see what i have
do you see what i have it's like you
have your trigger
i forgot to turn it i thought there was
some coping related
things does it
[Music]
i realized when i got home and i'm
emptying my bag that i had it with me
and you didn't
i'm sure you're not the only person that
did that
well i'm the only person i know of so i
guess i'd have to bring it back over to
the clerk
well when they when they switched over
to
the new voting system we used to have a
key
we in the legislature when we had
he had to turn a key to turn around
voting system
and they switched it over to the one we
have now
all those keys were there so i have my
key from the last seat wow
that i had was section four seek 4622
i have my key they put them out if you
want you keep
and i tell people particularly from out
of state
the venues where we have met this year
you know
uh a hockey rink a
lacrosse field
a parking lot driving style
and then the indoor soccer facility
you know it's people are fascinated by
that
but to me they've all worked
you know they truly have
fascinated isn't usually the reaction
that i believe
the parking lot one was the most
cheapest
yeah and it was the least
friendly i mean you know i don't know if
i other than to go to the bathroom i
saved my truck
it was different i come from a family of
all my kids by baseball so
what i've told people that we've had to
bet some sports class
you know they look at me because
softball meets for practices or indoor
scrimmages
it's very very very common to meet there
and suddenly you think
i get the looks from some people that
like friends
yeah i think
i have three grandkids that live in
litchfield
and they've all played yeah different
sports
football soccer softball
and now ed grandpa was there for
absolutely absolutely
good stuff
once we get our work done
[Music]
my granddaughter speaking of sports my
granddaughter
is a senior this year
and they're undefeated yeah litchfield
is kind of known for so far
very no not kind of very nice yeah
they're undefeated and
so they have a game tonight and
so i'm sitting here thinking about that
you know
it's amazing how uh how something
that many people would think would be
inconsequential brightens your day
all i have to do is think about my
granddaughter
and i'm on the nav there you go
now have you been to many of your games
almost everyone
we had a wedding on saturday they had a
game on saturday
and she had a wonderful day
division three college in waterville
maine
thomas hello
my daughter plays with tops so between
scrimmages
uh nescafe games she's played all up and
down there
the seacoast so yes i know thomas very
well
good for her congratulations okay
there have been have been several
kids from campbell who have gone on
but i think they've been kind of high
and
you're playing division one it's all
consumed
you know if you can't do anything
you can't do a straight wonder i wanted
to be a nurse
she couldn't go into nursing right
because she was playing soccer
right so
you know she's she's done very well
she's
she's been the number one pitcher now
for three years
last year
messes me up i think two years ago
and being able to
there are 10 seniors oh wow
there's 28 girls on the squad
they've drawn the floor you know
the ranks but uh
and for some of these girls
[Music]
the ones that aren't as
there was a lady
but of
[Music]
is
well good luck to your granddaughters
uh
oh that's fine i just assumed
i'm a nobody you're the king
welcome back everybody we're we're going
to begin the hearing
on senate bill 88
which is legislation relative to
broadband it's an omnibus bill so
bear with us as we uh as we go through
it
hopefully senator khan is with us yes i
see him
zooming in senator welcome to the
municipal county government uh house
committee
if you would excuse me like to introduce
the bill
the floor is yours thank you chairman
dolan i appreciate
the introduction and opportunity
senate bill 88 is
an omnibus bill but i can i'm sure you
can see
the relationship among the three
different parts here
all relating to broadband
implementations
these are primarily cleanup
pieces they though they cover
different parts of statute that
affect the installation of broad
i believe senator bradley is here to
uh talk about part two of the bill
uh and hopefully uh senator ward is here
for part three and if not
uh i think i can answer some of the
questions but hopefully you can inform
me if she is here
i i am uh by the way uh senator jay kahn
i represent 15 of 23 towns in cheshire
county
and uh i i am the
the prime uh sponsor of part one
here which is uh specific to something
that we adopted
the last legislative season uh relative
to
allowing for communication districts
to form uh much like we
would allow for a water district to
form between several municipalities
this allows that for broadband purposes
what we discovered as towns began to
work with what was passed last year is
that there was a
double approval because the language was
just
not accurate enough so
this clean up here by striking some of
the words
makes it very clear that when two
municipalities have
acted on their own to
approve a communication district that
the district shall be formed
and that is the nature of part one and
i'm glad to take any questions and again
i'll
i'll hang on the uh hearing to
see if you need me for any other part of
the bill
thank you senator i appreciate your time
and
we're going to work through lunch and
we've been terminated the day after
senate bill 88
so mr chairman i'll just i'll just add
i've got a judiciary meeting at one and
i gotta
move from one place to another so anyway
i'm probably
i'm good for the next 15 minutes for
sure thank you
any questions to senator khan yes
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
for taking my
question uh if you're strike
in a vote of the victim of legislative
wives which means you don't have to go
to town meetings
to get uh authorization but who's the
acquainting authority uh
i i don't know enough about the bill uh
as
it stands now so i don't know since
you're
stripping a board of the respective
legislative bodies
i'm trying to figure out who would make
the appointments
and who would determine whether or not
the uh
party with the degree would be
is that that's
yes uh representative uh that is how i
see it
uh that uh upon
the approval to form uh such a district
each uh
municipality would name two
uh people to it and this could be a five
town and i'll just give you outside of
my
territory but in the lakes region they
very much are thinking about
uh creating a
uh multi-town uh planning group
uh that and and so what we found with
this
is that if the
uh bodies create the special committee
that
one they would create the special
committee and then two they would seek
the vote
of the legislative bodies and so they
were having to go through
both steps and towns were coming back
and saying
hey you know we aren't able to form
these districts
until a year later after we've
determined that
we we want to participate in the
district
then we've got to go back to the
legislative body to get their vote
so that this is uh coming before you
thank you uh representative power
thank you mr chairman and um thank you
senator for taking this question
unfortunately i'm
still unclear as to
the process and what's not clear to me
is a communications district that first
formed and then this planning committee
is formed out of that or it's what
is being proposed to be formed as a
committee
first and then a district a
communications district
then formed are there two things being
formed or what
it's not clear it is one it is
the it is to create the committee uh it
would take then a warrant article
by each town to authorize
participation in the district and any
kind of funding arrangement
to to move the district forward
follow-up yes so um do i understand it
correctly that
the governing boards of
two or more municipalities will move
forward to establish this committee
without um buying it from the
legislative body
i believe that's true i believe
i believe that that is the case i'm
gonna
go check that statute because it's a
fairly short uh
section uh thank you thank you
any other questions for the senator
seeing none let's uh move section two
to be introduced by senator bradley
welcome senator
good morning how are you good
so uh thank you very much uh jeb bradley
from senate district 3 and pleased to be
here with senator khan
in support of senate bill 88 which the
senate adopted
unanimously so section 2
was a request of um
many different communities that are in
the planning
process of trying to develop broadband
and what it would do
was allow so-called one-touch
application
to simplify the deployment of wires
on poles oftentimes
there's a process between an electric
utility a phone utility
um cable utility um
so what this would do
would implement the onetouch fcc
plan and lead to cost reductions
and it would prevent duplication so
that's why we're supporting it the
senate adopted it the one change i might
ask you to
make mr chairman is to make this
section effective on passage
any questions for senator brad
i have a question uh senator in
on page two of the bill line
lines four three through nine talks
about
um the party agreed to the following
alternative timelines but there's
nothing following there is there
is that uh am i not understanding the
bill correctly
this is a page two uh line six and nine
so there's a um
the commission the public utilities
commission would have to implement
uh timelines for uh
the deployment of um
or excuse me of the rules process for
how this would work
and then this language would mean that
any agreements would have to function
within those timelines
i had a hard time hearing your question
but as i heard it i think
it would facilitate uh cooperation
between
various entities that had uh wires on
poles
and by having a process to do so would
make
this a much less duplicative process
it would prevent delay uh it would lead
to
better implementation and cost savings
so
that's the purpose of uh this one touch
um initiative which as
as you see at the bottom of page one um
it's adopted by the federal
communications commission
already so this is not um
something really radically new and
different
any other questions yes uh
representative tripp
i'm sorry i'm standing up to sell it
yes uh senator bradley thanks for taking
my question would the
scope of this bill
also impact non-wired
utilities for instance cell phones
or satellite satellite technology
no no this is um
you know just a one touch make ready for
a wired infrastructure
and that would include fiber optics am i
correct
yes anything that's wired and fiber
optic is a wired technology but
not satellite um technology
thank you uh representative mentioned uh
reporter thank you mr chair thank you
senator bradley i
i guess i'm seeking a clarification too
and i'm remembering
the bill that uh representative pimanchi
was speaking about that we got last year
um getting telephone poles taken down
was a process because many different
organizations were attaching their wires
and then one by one they would have to
take
take them off took a long time to do
that was holding up progress
i'm understanding that this provision
that you're putting forward here
would eliminate that need for the one
one of the time kind of situation is
that
am i right about that yeah under a
protocol
established by the public utilities
commission then
you would be able to um
facilitate the you know installation the
quicker installation
of any of the wires going on polls
that's correct okay thank you senator
yes sir representative powell thank you
mr chairman and thank you senator
bradley for taking my question
the question is under the one touch make
ready
i guess program if you will um
where does the field service crews come
from and what
because you have different utilities
companies
attaching their wires to the utility
poles
and so utility um you know their
field service technicians are trained
and certified for that particular
utility
and my understanding is this one touch
makes
make ready utilizes a single field
um service technician team
and i was wondering where does those
teams come from
and how are they trained to be able to
um move all different types of
utility lines so
my understanding is that there would
have to be cooperation
obviously between the the various
utilities but i think if you look
at line seven on page two
there's going to be a rule-making
process
to implement this at the public
utilities commission
this um you know part two of
senate bill 88 merely authorizes
and directs the commission to move
forward with that
um procedure
what follow up um so i i wonder
um is it possible i guess my concern is
with it would they be third party
um you know utility field service
technicians
or would these um one touch make ready
teams
be comprised of different members
i guess that would make sense because
you would need to have you would
ultimately want one person in the
lift bucket moving the wires so that
that individual that would have to be
trained and certified across
all different utilities is that correct
you know
that would be um a question if
anybody from the puc is um
on this call to ask of them my
understanding is that they
if you look at line seven they're going
to have to adopt rules pursuant to
541a um for negotiating and implementing
the poll attachments so
um you know that kind of
detail is left to the rulemaking process
you
anyone else have a question of
representative gallagher
so yeah um this is kind of a follow up
to replace alice's question
um his was about wire
so yeah it's about um applicability of
yeah what this applies to his was about
wired versus wireless mine is about
um different kinds of wires so
it talks about poll attachment
agreements but what about
municipalities that have decided to
bury their wires instead of
attaching them to poles how does that
apply here
well again i think if you look at the
language
on page two starting in line five
this really is about pole attachments
next up we have uh mark dean like
ask the question
mr dean are you available i am available
yes
my name is mark dean i'm the general
counsel for new hampshire electric
cooperative
and i have submitted uh written
testimony
and i think i can maybe shed light on a
couple of the questions that have been
asked of senator bradley um the the
co-op
wears two hats in this environment now
it used to be
since 1939 it was just one hat
electricity
um but the co-op is now embarking on
efforts to make sure
that broadband service is available to
its
members so it has uh done some broadband
installations
uh so we are familiar with the
issue of make ready work both as
a poll owner we own about a hundred
thousand
polls in the state of new hampshire and
if the co-op builds out a broadband
system it will mainly be using those
poles but it will also be attaching to
poles that are owned by cci and maybe
some by eversource or other utilities so
we're on both sides of the
the transactions if you will we strongly
support
this bill uh and strongly support the
suggestion that senator bradley made
about amending the effective date to be
as
out of passage uh instead of 60 days
after passage and
that's because really all this bill does
is
start the clock running on a puc rule
making process
and uh as many of you may know that's a
process
both at the commission and then going
through jalcar afterwards
takes a number of months in the best of
circumstances
so the earlier the puc gets started on
that the better as far as we're
concerned because
many entities will hopefully be out
there in 2021 trying to expand broadband
services
in new hampshire and uh the availability
of the one touch
option is something that uh will help
speed
deployment uh just to step back a
few feet here which may help with some
of the questions so when we talk about
make ready work we're talking about
poles and we're talking either about
replacing a pole if the pole is too
small to accommodate the additional
attachment
or rearranging the attachments that
exist
on the pole in order to accommodate a
new additional attachment so a lot of
polls
there is no make ready work needed
there's just enough space
to have say a fiber cop fiber optic
cable added
many poles the attachments need to be
rearranged
and the way that has generally worked
is the entity that wants to add the new
attachment
that approaches the poll owner and
indicates that enters a poll attachment
agreement and then when polls are
identified
where attachments need to be moved
uh there's this process and this is
what's been mentioned in the bill that
was
in last year and is now
that got transformed into a commission
proposal to study
these we call them orphaned polls where
the last entity that was supposed to get
off the pole
in this process doesn't do it and so you
end up with two poles
standing there for quite some time um
so in the make the one touch make ready
essentially uh the parties can agree
and an attacher can insist if the own
poll owner can't do it quickly enough
that a third-party contractor
will basically come in and they'll move
each of the attachments
so that's the one touch so it's one stop
instead of having one utility move their
equipment
then they put in a notice to the other
utilities that we've got our job done
and then
each one sequentially comes out and does
it
it moves the pace of things along the
entity
that requested the attachment to begin
with
is still going to be responsible for the
cost associated with it nothing
changes there the system just becomes
more efficient
and to the one question that was asked
about
qualifications the way the fcc system
works
is that every utility every poll owner
is going to have to have a list of
approved contractors
to work on their polls
and also the reality especially in the
uh fiber deployment associated with
broadband is for the most part this work
is done
by specialty contractors
anyways it's not usually going to be
utility
workers doing the work so from the
co-ops perspective
this is an improvement it doesn't shift
cost responsibilities from one party to
another over the existing arrangements
but it will be more efficient and we
believe more cost effective
and hopefully faster which i think is
what
senator bradley was trying to achieve
here
senator khan did you have a question or
was that your hand up
from before
i assume that i assume yes thank you
thank you mr chairman
i i just wanted to get back to represent
power
if i might uh to say
that the communication district and its
forming parallels the person that a
a town or municipality would use
so the formation of a committee
does not require anything more than
a action by the legislative body
board of selectmen town council city
council
and it is it is merely to enter
into a joint uh planning
and and that's that's the goal of the
establishing the communication district
there's no obligation
that the communication district
actually form should that form for the
purpose of
moving forward with a broadband project
then
that would take an action of the
town and municipality
any questions uh further about
representative
monty of the question thank you
um
that many polls what is the estimated
time frame believe this project
can you hear me i've been having a
little problem getting unmuted okay
great
um so i guess your ques is your question
how long
a project would take or how long would
a project covering the co-op service
territory i
i'm not sure the scope of the question
for completion i
again i didn't really hear what the
project was
uh my question uh was uh estimated time
of completion
of uh this uh project that you have a
hundred thousand plus polls
oh um i guess all i could say at this
point is multi-year it's not like there
is a
full 100 000 poll
project you know on the books for the
co-op it's in the process of
developing that plan but it's a
multi-year
plan under any set of circumstances
thank you any further questions about
section two before we move on to part
three
uh representative status
thank you for taking my question um
does the uh tesla starlink uh
project is that projected to have any
impact
on the the project for the hundred
thousand polls
well the existence of starlink as with
potential competition
from you know any other source it'll be
a factor that
goes into the into the thinking of it
any other any other questions that you
need to follow up or you could
i i guess a follow-up if i may
so i'm not quite sure
about the answer that i just got it
seemed a little
waffley if you will but um i mean have
you
actually integrated the tesla starlink
project in your planning
and has it affected the numbers in any
way
or your projections i guess
i um won't testify about the specific
financial projections that the co-op's
using for its
business plan but it has taken into
account
and looked at the uh
the competitive threat or the effect
that starlink may have on
the number of consumers served by the
co-op that would
take its service so it has taken that
into account
thank you that's much more helpful thank
you before we go to section
three uh just for those who are keeping
track of these types of numbers
uh you've had people sign in on this
bill
71 or in support zero oppose it
zero or neutral about it so those like i
said those will keep track of those
numbers there they are
so our next uh discussion is going to be
on part three of the bill
which is gonna be introduced by senator
ward
the floor is yours
sending the request over mr chair okay
entirely possibly some reward might be
compromised with another meeting
okay while we wait for her to uh to come
back to us we have
uh carol monroe
who is a member of the public would like
to speak
go ahead carol um good morning and um
yes um thank you chairman dolan and all
the members of the municipal
and county government committee i'm
going to speak to all three sections if
you don't mind at the
at this time um but i think i can
clarify some of the questions that have
come
up um in part one relative to the
creation of communication districts
the current the current rules under 53
g2 what are that
in order to form the committee you had
to go to town meeting
in order to request to be a district to
be approved you have to go to town
meeting which we
which then required a two-year or more
process
this uh change allows for the committee
to be appointed
by the select board for the city council
members of the committee of two or more
towns and then that committee
will look at the reasonableness of
creating a communication
district and respond back to the town
for approval at town meeting the next
town meeting
so the the general public does have an
opportunity to weigh in at town meeting
on the final decision but all the work
and planning
and feasibility and business planning
will be done by the committee
up front and that committee can be
appointed now
with this change by the select board
and it makes it makes it so that it will
go much quicker
in the process in part two
i'm certainly in support of one touch
make ready it will simplify the process
and yes generally speaking
um it is one um an outsourced third
party
that does the make ready work even today
so
in essence this will just streamline the
process
and allow for that to be the norm
instead of the
instead of a possibility where one
third party that's a third party that is
on the list of those
attachers on the pole will go and move
the equipment on the poles down to make
ready for the new
participant a new attacher
it is something that's already being
done across the country
and it will streamline the process here
the second part of this
part two really has to do with the
administrative rules
currently the puc 1300 utility poll
attachment rules
include a requirement to negotiate
agreement
with the poll owners and this
this particular issue is that
you have much smaller internet service
providers negotiating with very large
multi-state entities and what has
happened in the past
is that they have held up the approval
of
an agreement until you
gave up some of the rules that have been
established in
chapter puc 1300 utility poll
attachments
and so to make sure that we
all follow the existing rules
established by the puc which might
include one touch make ready going
forward
we need to make sure that all agreements
are agreements that follow those rules
and not negotiating away the rules that
have been established
that's what's in part two there
part three relative to bonding issue
um currently the timeline is 60 60 days
to respond to an rfi
that shortens it to 30. once again
trying to move this process along fairly
quickly
and then the second piece of that is in
the past
the cable providers have found it
difficult to respond to their rfi
and in many cases did not and we
remedied
put in a remedy last year that
indicated that if they didn't respond
then we would consider it to be an
unserved area in town
but in fact what they have suggested is
that they can respond with a map
that that can identify the first address
on a street
that can reach that can receive cable
and the last on every street in town
so for an example you know the cable is
available on main street from
premises number 13 to
premises 256 and everything in between
but but what we've seen from the cable
companies in this past year
was hand-drawn maps sometimes
highlighted
with colors and
or and or street maps which have been
highlighted but
but no indication of where the cable
starts and stops and so therefore no
indication
of where there is service and where
there is not
and so this section just clarifies the
need to have that very
to have very specific addresses
identified
as to where they have service so we can
determine
who is unserved in that town and so
those are the three areas um
within this bill and i'm happy to take
any questions you might have
um this is as senator khan
represented this is really a cleanup
bill of some
legislation that's already in place
uh ms monroe you seem to be very well
read on this issue but
my list of speakers just as you're
representing yourself as a member of the
public do you have a
different time for you i do
i'm the chair of the board for valley
net which is
an organization that does fiber to the
premise broadband construction
management and operations
for the upper valley in vermont and in
new hampshire
and have been their their ceo in the
past
i also have been part of the dublin new
hampshire broadband committee
and i've been working in this industry
for 20 years in various capacities
all right thank you so much for your
testimony is there are any
questions for ms monroe yes
representative porter
thank you mr chair uh miss monroe i'm
just curious
one of the problems that's come up a lot
when we're trying to get broadband out
to
especially rural areas is that last mile
issue you know where where i lived for a
long time we had
houses far apart
does this address that in any way i mean
i'm just not familiar enough with the
technology
and the issue so the the uh problem with
getting to the last mile
to that last address at the end of the
dirt road a mile up
um in new hampshire it's very common and
across
northern new england um is the cost of
doing so
and the then the fact that there are
only
five to six houses per mile in those
areas and so the costs
spread over those few numbers are are
higher
however when you form a communication
district and you bring together
all small towns and larger towns
then you're you're aggregating
that demand across a larger footprint
and so that costs will go down because
some areas will be a higher density in
some areas a lower density
so that's one item there the second is
communication districts
by by their nature are are about
universal access meaning access to all
not just to those that are
in which you can have a return on
investment as a municipal communication
district
your you're less concerned about your
return on your investment
than you are about getting service to
every
resident in your community every premise
in your community um so by nature by
that nature
you're looking at universal access and
that's the goal is to get to there
and that that plays into
the ability to bond for those
and the ability to attach to the polls
in a very timely manner
at a much lower cost as well as the
creation of the district itself
thank you for your follow-up to follow
up on that
when these districts are formed and the
broadband eventually
gets installed is the cost to the met
the people who
have now have broadband the thing
regardless of where they live within the
district
so is my neighbor who lives three miles
down the dirt road
going to pay the same monthly fee as i
do
that lives in town yes absolutely
i mean that's one of the purposes of the
district is so that the costs are the
same
across the entire district thank you
thank you do you have anybody else
online from the senate who would like to
talk to section
or part three of the bill
uh thank you the uh the only action that
i see
that i made note of was that senator
bradley mentioned in
part two that he thought that the
effective effectivity had to be changed
from
60 days after the passage to immediately
after passing
anybody hear anything differently
yes
uh are there any other questions or
comments from
the committee the municipal and county
committee on this bill
for closing here
mr chair yes i'm not a question but just
uh we had two people signed up to speak
uh three people i can find two of them
maura weston who i believe has just
raised her hand okay i cannot find
representative bixby on there
and there's one other horse named
escapes in the i think
jim isaac yes thank you
uh well let's go to uh who i can find
also
is miss weston available to speak
good morning good morning
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak with you today my name is mara
weston
and i'm testifying today on behalf of
the new england cable and
telecommunications association
our members including atlantic broadband
charter and comcast
are new hampshire's leading broadband
and communications providers
in new hampshire with over 450 000
customers in more than 184 communities
our members are proud to be the first
providers to offer gigabit speeds
throughout their networks my comments
today are specifically focused on part
three
of senate bill 88 and we do
support the bill the language
in part three of senate bill 88
streamlines and makes more efficient
the rfi process relative to the issuance
of bonds for financing broadband
infrastructure
rfis are required by statute so the
communities can determine for the
purpose of issuing an rfp
what locations in town are unserved
specifically the rfi process is
recruited by this bill in two very
important ways
first the bill creates an interested
provider list by
town maintained by the office office of
strategic initiatives
such that those issuing rfis will have
the correct contact information
for all interested providers this will
limit confusion
or lack of response when a town
unintentionally fails to issue an rfi to
a provider
in their town or they issue it to the
wrong employee or the wrong
address secondly the bill clarifies what
information providers are required
to include in their responses to rfi
these two changes in law update the rfi
process allowing for more timely
and informative responses i would
however like to draw your attention to
what we believe
is a drafting error on line
33 of page
2.
and that says
the the intention of this section is
that when a town issues an rfp
after having collected information and
data through the rfi
process that town will identify which
street segments
have been unserviceable so that
providers will know what the
municipality is proposing to build
so we believe that the correct term in
that line should be
not serviceable but rather unserviceable
and we're happy to to provide more
specific
language or markup but i think that
that's a drafting error
so we appreciate the opportunity to work
with the sponsors and the stakeholders
although this bill may not be perfect
from every perspective
it reflects negotiations and compromise
reached by parties who came together
with a shared goal of addressing the
challenges of broadband deployment
for the greater good in new hampshire
and we certainly appreciate the
opportunity to testify today
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
you might have
any questions from the committee yes
representative gallagher um
so with the um
list being maintained by the office of
street future initiatives
so if um
if governor sununu's plan to split
the office and reorganize it goes
through do you know
um what what will happen to
like which half of the office the
list will go with where where that those
responsibilities will fall
i imagine i i don't have an answer for
for you specifically
um you know we had thought and
working with the sponsors thought that
osi was an appropriate place to kind of
house this
list and i imagine in the reorganization
process
it would follow to the new department of
energy
um if that's created if certainly there
needs to be a tweak
um we'd be happy to work on it to make
sure that
um there is a predictable process in
place that
that continues along regardless of what
happens with with the office
and the potential formation of the
department of energy
okay thank you mr preston uh we have a
request to speak from uh mr isaac are
you with us mr isaac
thank you can you hear me yes great
well thank you chairman nolan and uh
committee members
uh i'm a member of the general public
and not one of the
representatives of any organization or
commercial interests but i have a very
strong interest in broadband
and the ability for having affordable
access across all of new hampshire
it's a passion of mine for literally 50
years
in various ways that i've worked on
i really support this bill very strongly
and i'm going to really focus on section
3 because i think it does one thing
that's very important
and then this is one thing that i think
is also important they're really two
serious issues we face with incumbent
suppliers
and they're to put a bluntly
unwillingness to actually provide
service uh their purpose of course is to
make money which makes perfect sense
they're pri
for
and as soon as they run to situations
where that no longer makes sense it's
hard for them to justify taking action
to provide service
so there needs to be a way for towns
to determine what level service they
actually need
and this really is a local control issue
in my mind towns do zoning towns do
school type activities
they decide the personality broadband
has become an infrastructure
that's critical for towns to determine
their own personalities
in a rapidly changed area 20 years ago
this was not really an issue and
right now it's almost inconceivable that
towns don't take a proactive role in
thinking
what should we have do we have it do we
not have it
so with that context let me point to the
specifics in the bill
the concept of actually having detailed
information
about which addresses are served or
unserved
and for every address in town i'll just
point out that's one way or the other
uh it's either served or unserved and
so it really doesn't matter whether a
incumbent supplier
basically documents every served address
or documents every unserved address
the key thing is the town needs to know
where the service goes and where it
stops
and i think the by address definition is
a very important one
the second thing which is not addressed
here directly
is the problem of what what does it mean
to be served
the current fcc specification is 25
megabits down
three megabits up that's barely
sufficient in fact it's so
insufficient the comcast recently
upgraded their essential service for
um low-income houses to be 50 down and
five
up at their 10 a month rate i don't
think that's at
cost so i appreciate their willingness
to do that
but it also reflects the kind of level
of service that's needed to provide
viable
service today in that context again i
hope towns would have the ability to
specify what they think
adequate service is and not settle for
whatever the fcc
has done some towns will be very happy
with whatever the essay is specified
or very happy potentially with what
their incumbent suppliers are doing
others will find that inadequate to meet
their uh objectives for education
for employment uh for the kind of
industry they might attract and so forth
um in that respect i'd be very tempted
to make one change and i realize you're
really not in a position to do this
but i'll just mention it anyway which is
to change unserved
to underserved you can have service at
25 30 or at least a vendor who claims to
have service at 25
30 and still have an underserved
community
to meet the town's objectives uh it's
pointed out in
billy senate bill 85 that the objective
for the
state in that context is targeting a
gigabit
which is an excellent target but it's
certainly not
going to be a unserved community
uh that's an underserved situation where
25 3 might be served but not sufficient
to meet the town or
objectives of the state for a gigabit
so i'll point that out and uh i'd be
happy to answer any questions i might
that you might have for me thank you
okay thank you um mr isaac thank you
take my question what line were you
talking about
i'm having trouble hearing i'm sorry
that it's breaking up
on the bill itself uh were you looking
i still did not get the question i'm
sorry
what what line of the bill were you
looking for a change
uh well to put it bluntly it's not just
this bill
uh the definition of service actually
goes back to rsas that are already in
present
uh that reference fcc guidelines for
what defines service
uh so it would be essentially replacing
served uh areas with un under
unserved areas with underserved areas
in this bill but also in other
legislation
which is probably beyond the scope of
this bill so
i would love to see it done but i don't
know that you actually are in a position
to do it
at this point are there any other
questions for mr isaac
from the committee uh yes representative
gallagher
yeah um just wondering um did you also
email testimony to us previously are you
that same jim
isaac yes that's me okay
um in the email you said you were with
the ieee but now you're saying
that you're not with any organization
could you clarify
that for us i have a great deal of
expertise having worked with ieee
as a volunteer for many years including
chairing the communications
policy committee but it is not an ieee
position
uh that i represent here it's my own
personal position
okay thanks okay and uh
we had senator ward uh queued up
to talk to us about section relative
part three of the bill
but because of our our schedule here
she was unable to stay but she did send
me a note i'm gonna read it
she says part three improves upon the
process that municipalities must adhere
to
in order to issue bonds for the purpose
of financing
the development of broadbrand
infrastructure
additionally it instructs the office of
strategic initiatives
to maintain a list of all providers by
town interested in receiving requests
for information
just a short two sentence
email so that's in the record from
senator ward who was the uh
sponsor section for around part three
are there any other questions or
comments
are always interesting mr chair i would
only know that uh well we've done two
things
representative oxham has uh has a hand
up and i had a
question going back maybe for our
executive session
about the the difference between
serviceable and unserviceable
uh in there that i was hoping to ask a
moral question but i think it might be
proven to go to representative box in
first
sure
mr oxenham you're uh you're up please uh
please take the floor
you have to unmute yourself
there i finally achieved it thank you
very much for taking my
very brief comment um i also have a um
house bill uh dealing with broadband
which has been retained in the science
technology and energy committee and i'd
like to be involved and i'd like to have
our committee involved if we possibly
can be
i know it's at a very late date
but i think that the the general goal
here
is uh completely congruent we're all
looking
for the achievement of universal access
to broadband
for our constituents so i strongly
support the bill before you
i would suggest one change where
it specifies osi i would say
or its successor agency
agency may not be the best term there
but
i i know i have consulted with ols and
they won't allow us to change to do
because doe doesn't exist yet but we
don't want to
um incorporate into law that we have to
do something with an agency that's not
no longer going to exist so that's all i
had thank you
okay thank you uh i'm just looking for
the reference to osi
i believe it was in section three where
they're talking about the list of
contractors that would be maintained
page three um line
bye thank you
okay thank you very much any questions
for the representative
seeing nuns um about to close the
hearing on
senate bill 88 many last-minute comments
objections
seeing none the hearing is now closed
thank you for all uh that has come with
us
to get this testimony on the record i
greatly appreciate that
[Music]
for those on the committee
administrative note
we will reconvene next monday
at 9am thank you very much and have a
great rest of the week